wanted to tell everyone who's here for
the licensing of
acupuncture that that section has been
removed from the amendment so so all
that to do with
acupuncture has been removed from the
amendment does anybody have any
questions about
acupuncture no okay great um the next
one has to do with let me just go back
let me see if I can
find the mlac board I know that there's
someone here from them and um what we
had um because that also is not going to
be addressed by any of the upcoming
bills that's going to
stay um and then I was given some
changes where are they oh here they are
from the emac board on some housekeeping
about just a moment it had to do with
um RSA
330c
colon 16 Roman
numeral Das 2- a either had to do with
um
credentialing and that's been removed
that's going to be removed from the bill
so is there any questions or concerns
from the
mlc people yes please one of the um oplc
if if we could have oplc board
Representatives come and speak that
would be great and if anybody has any
questions from the commit just raise
your
hand Elizabeth Eaton board counsel to
the board of licensed Alcohol and Other
Drug use counselors y um and the board
just wanted to note a couple of things
um thank you for updating on what's
already been changed um which version
are you working with so that I will on
the same page as you I
have the original and then I have the
clean C copy the the new copy okay let's
work with the original
okay
um
on on page eight of the
original there's it's at the top of the
page line one um it adds a section Roman
numeral
2A um and the language is unclear
neither the board nor I understood what
that was
adding that's being removed okay is that
the one it's on top of page six for me
oh okay I apologize do you see it on top
of page six yes okay that's being taken
out thank
you um and then just two of the repeals
were also um we had questions about that
um is this on page seven yes so the
first one is it RSA 330- C colon 3
relative to the liability of the
board that's been moved to RSA 310 okay
is that the only is that what you had no
so the the two concerns were related to
um RSA 330 C5 Roman numeral
7 which is repealing the um approval or
denial and withdrawal of approval for
providers of continuing
education uh and the board would like
that to stay in but maybe read criteria
for approval so that they're setting the
criteria um and then the office is
actually doing the issuing of approval
or
denial this is
RSA
330-
c57 Roman Ral 7
yes and I believe on that page it's on
line 13 yep I I see it and I have it
this was part the response from oplc was
that this has to do with licensing and
fees
the this is for the relative to the
powers and duties of the board is um 330
C5
okay um and so page okay I'm GNA just
myself and not okay page
seven and it has to do just with with
the co with the Roman numeral 7 right
yes under 33 C5 Roman numeral 7 yeah
that's it talking about just this one
good
okay all right I'll look into that do do
you have if the board or you could come
up with some yes I alternative language
that would be great absolutely and then
one more
um and this is just kind of
a the the board is just wanting to make
you aware that this would be removed um
it's on the same page line 18 so RSA 330
c165 MH that is relative to the issuance
of an mlad act license in that provision
um it is if a if an applicant does not
meet the requirements for an mlac but
they do meet the requirements for leac
that allows the uh the issuance of a lak
license under that same application uh
and the board would would like to keep
that uh if it does not conflict with the
uh 310 statute okay can you um check
with Doug and Doug Mr O OST house yes
absolutely and I believe that's
everything that I have on behalf of the
board
okay thank you so after um that we have
barbering and cosmetology are there any
comments okay yes um I also represent
barbering and cosmetology and I have um
there
um so this
is okay um I'm going to go
Section 23 I believe on your page eight
yes maintenance of Records oh no
barbering c yeah yes maintenance of
Records right now that line five says
the board shall maintain a record but I
believe this should be the office
maintaining those
office okay there's an editorial
issue on line nine um it should just say
certificates um within space between and
page um report to the office of
professional licensure and certification
all violation
of this chapter that I believe should be
repealed as it it's an oplc
function
um we did try to get the office's
opinion on on these changes that the
board counsil noted um and time just did
not allow the communication back from
the office so we're making these
proposals um and if general counsel
disagrees then that's fine okay
yeah
right yes it's because in 655 last year
we um changed the responsibility of
Licensing to a office function and also
change yes the amend these are just
oversights
so it should be on line five on page
eight it should be the office shall
board yes that's right because either
are the respon these are the duties of
the board I know it's that's why we have
to go through this no because these are
the responsibility of the board
underneath this and these are sort
of it's not a continuum of
though
or no because the um the office is where
that the office is the administration of
oplc and the board are those like the
Board of Cosmetology the board of and
they are they are responsible for for
example setting up a standards and there
they're two different
functions I know I wish they were thank
Eaton continue okay thank you um on the
um the we have an outstanding question
with the office that uh we haven't
received feedback on but I did want to
make um you aware as the sponsor that uh
the criteria for licensing shops was not
included in this section can you tell me
what what line or it's just not in here
okay are we talking about uh Roman num
3 so it would be included near in
between um and since this was repealed
and re and U reenact I don't know where
it would go but in the original language
there's um a section 10 which um is Ru
making for conditions and standards for
operation under a shop license including
health and safety standards didn't we
get rid of shop licenses we got rid of
booth rental licenses Booth rentals okay
but shop licenses are pretty important
and especially the health and safety
standards yeah um so again I haven't
received feedback from the office on
that but
okay and that was section 10
correct um so where did that go okay so
I don't know it could
go I'll we'll we'll find yes I'm sure
you
will
um and there's a number of places where
uh I think direct Courtney has already
noted using criteria established by the
board should be added um and so I have
noted those in my copy but I think
Lindsay direct according also already
noted those areas so I'm not going to go
through every single one right unless no
but as long as um
so so it's the criteria set by the board
here okay this is underneath barbery
barbering
okay
okay um and that's that's everything
that I have for barbering there are a
few things that maybe beyond the scope
of this amendment that the board would
like to change but I don't want to bring
it up if it's beyond the scope so okay
thank you right okay thank you so now
um see barbering and cosmetology goes on
for some time body
art is there anything we um Ria medley
board Council
um we didn't have any changes for the
section involving body art from the
board counsel perspective
right
okay we have the board of dental
examiners were there any changes
involved with that um just there was
Chiropractic yes Chiropractic before yep
yep uh is it are you okay if I go
through that yes if you just tell me
what page you're on yes hi hi uh page
line page
15 so start out LC page 15
line where is it your's a different yeah
mine is me get
okay okay you want to tell me what page
to start with um for Chiropractic or do
you want to wait on body art no for
Chiropractic okay uh Chiropractic we're
on
page yeah it's just that oh okay uh sure
I'll let me just let me note this so I
don't forget this
um Mr ound if you want to jump in and
join everybody at the microphone you can
but we're we're taking it like yeah um
on page 15 line 36 we wrote office of
professional lure and responsibility and
not certification so it's just
a I see line
36 can you repeat
that it says office of professional lure
and responsibility yes section 48
yes it should be in
certification
oh all right thank
you is there anything else on
Chiropractic or is that it that was body
art okay um Chiropractic um no I mean
page 15 is chiropractic
renewal oh I apologize um but just to be
clear Douglas oser's how was discussing
a section within but okay sorry I
apologize
um so um are we
at I'm at
um section
43 on the original copy line 44 this has
to do with Chiropractic correct line
44 um how about
qualifications what page you on um my
copy
[Music]
is I think I think on yours it's page 14
yep okay um at the bottom of the page
uh it says should say criteria
area set by the board is that what
you're saying um it's 44 uh section 44
Chiropractic fees qualifications amend
RSA
316a um colon 11 Roman numeral
one um this I I just want to make sure
that this is not on page 14 and my copy
okay I don't deal with can we deal with
what you the paper so that if you're
just dealing with something that's I
can't follow you right and so I'm we got
move across theall so we're
not thank you okay thank you all right P
go
ahead
sorry thank you thank you thank you are
you talking about Chiropractic fees and
qualifications section 44 yes okay I I
okay go ahead we we are on SEC what's
each applicant shall pay to the Prof
office of professional liur
certification fee established by the
board office corre is that what you're
reading yes that is what I'm reading
okay um so this section in the statute
was uh referencing fees uh there were
other various items within there um that
needed to be addressed um and I believe
this needed to be with the office uh
just to review and revise um that
section there were just some um items
that weren't picked up within
um within 316 A5 which needs to be
well Mr oout do you do you have a
that
again my question was just what the
references so I can take a look at it
modification um three
5 and then I believe
316a colon
yep so those just need to be addressed
office
thank better he lik all right well you
know what we'll have to deal with that
yeah
separately you might as well are we
still on
Chiropractic
moment uh no we're that was the only uh
those are the only so we can go to board
of dental examiners okay any comments on
examiners
let me let me just find it on your copy
real quick well maybe if you just tell
me what the section is called yep um
section
60 section 60
okay 60 wow and so it's on page 20 line
four yep uh failure to do so may result
in the board issuing a non-disciplinary
letter of concern to the leny this is
inappropriate under the um New statute
uh
oplc uh so it would be the office
issuing so I I believe this should be
struck this sentence should be
okay just as a comment if anyone is here
for the LNA qualifications they're
good okay and then now there any other
comments on dentistry and dental hygiene
which is the next one 61 just one uh
more comment uh it's in the repeal
section on page 21 okay uh again it's
just one that is missing from the repeal
section there's a there's a section in
the dental statute on the professional
health
program um this is an outstanding
question we have with the office uh
whether they need a section in their
statute on the professional health
program or if the oplc statute on the
professional health program
satisfies can you comment on that Mr do
thank you Lindsay Courtney executive
director oplc I think you could handle
it in one of two ways I don't view it as
a conflict essentially there are three
boards that are statutorily authorized
to have a PHP um one is actually
mandatory I think for nursing um but
then the office has the ability to
provide a PHP pursuant to rules and or
contract and so we do provide a PHP to
other professions so I think you could
either repeal it um because I think we
already have the statutary authority or
I think you could just leave it as
is okay so what is your what's your
Eden I believe the board would like to
leave it as is okay so we don't it's not
missing then
no okay we don't need to address that
okay great um the next one has to do
with dietitians anything anybody here
for
dietitians no okay sorry Ricky a medley
board Council for dieticians yes um just
70 or is there something before that I
don't think so no uh the there weren't
anything there wasn't anything that
needed to be addressed for the
dieticians on the original copy or 71
okay then we are or 72 section 72
right or section
74 so that would be that would bring us
electrolysis section
76 no uh we didn't have any changes for
at
electris
electrologist
[Music]
anology okay we're still
Ates oh okay funeral directors and ab
balers is there anyone want you have any
comments on that uh I'll be um here on
behalf of um Funeral Directors uh their
board council is unable to make this
um I have section 83 funeral directors
and embalmer section 86 Funeral
Directors qualification
I skipped 85 sorry on balmer's
qualifications uh largely these were um
the changes were fine um there are as
other professions there are some um
items for the future um that would need
to be adjusted um but at this time um I
don't I don't think it works with this
amendment
okay so nothing on Funeral Directors or
in
bombers if human
remains or there's nothing about that if
there's no con changes about that we can
go
to
um um there is one um
under excuse me section 99 uh Cremation
of human remains
uh it would need to change the language
from uh RSA
325A 11 to leave that um but to change
the language from board to
office okay so we're not going to repeal
that and we're going to change board to
office correct that that is um the
recommendation from uh the board okay
thank
you then we have repeals for massage
therapist and
massage
establishment since there's nothing that
board is not
changing right now we're going to those
are repealed I would imag there's
nothing about any changes there that's
correct no changes okay and Medical
Imaging and radiation
therapy uh no changes okay um the board
of registration of medical technicians
we're going to leave that in because
right now even though there's a proposal
to take it out we we don't have that
hasn't passed yet so we're going to
leave that
alone
um the board of okay medical
technicians
see okay physician assistance uh we have
no changes for physician assistance okay
good
[Music]
Midwifery the changes noted to the
Midwifery statute here are only related
to whether they stay a statutory board
or go to advisory um if they go to
advisory the changes are fine if they
stay statutory they should change some
of these back from Office board so which
ones should change because that's that's
a proposal and we haven't passed that
yet so I don't want to make any conflict
with what's going on right now so what
needs to
change
uh so should we leave all the language
that's been struck out for example no
but I can um I can get you a full
written copy of what's here as as should
be changed back um okay yeah I can send
you
okay
T okay tele medicine has to do with okay
naturopathic health care practice
anything
there K ke medley uh representing a
naturopathic uh board uh no change
uh noted from the language that was
great nurse Practice
Act
129 yes we have a few things noted here
um under
Authority okay hang on a
second under Roman numeral 4 let me find
um where the heck is
that oh yes okay R number
y the stand be meant by and the process
approval for right so the process for
approval of yes is now an oplc function
and should be stricken that that phrase
so the standards to be met by education
program so we just correct okay take
that
out okay further in Roman numeral 7 yes
says the administration of examinations
and administration is now no PLC
function It should read the requirements
for or criteria for either one of those
would
criteria for the administration of is
that what it's going to
Administration
okay we'll deal with that we we can talk
about that separately okay
all right um in uh Roman numeral 10 and
I I believe the office also flagged this
um persons regulated by the board it has
in the original Amendment it has that
stricken in office uh it should be
board and retired persons regulated by
the board as
well
right all right and then we're at we're
continuing anything else on the nurse
Practice
Act yes okay um Roman
numeral 13 yes um this process for
registering practitioners it's a uh the
de registration is not a a nursing uh
function this normal noral 13 should be
stricken
entirely it's not a function of repeat
that it's it's not under the authority
of the nursing board to require
registration with the
DEA
though we so one of the things that
we're doing is we're trying to
oh that has to do with lnas never mind
all right fine okay um and then in uh
Roman numeral 14 it says the
implementation of strategies and
procedures uh and so procedures should
be stricken from that so it reads the
implementation of strategies
necessary
right yes representative goalie has a
question
I just want to go back
to um 13 process for registering mean I
understand the DEA does that process but
shouldn't we still be tracking those and
have a process of knowing who has that
under Federal Regulation and um
prescribing control
drugs why wouldn't we want to why
wouldn't we want to have a registry as
DEA uh Lindsay Corney oplc so we do try
the information the um statutory
Authority was limited to defining the
process for registering with the DEA
which is a pro the Deo DEA controls that
process so I don't know that we could uh
adopt rules that would conflict with the
DEA process for registering we do
capture that information as to whether
or not somebody has a DEA number um but
process just to clarify I read it as a
process for registering practitioners
who have been granted
special so it this is this is a process
for us not for a process to tell them
what to do is the way I read it it's a
process for the our lies to register
with the DEA but that's a DEA process
because our lenses aren't registered
they have a DEA registration our lenses
are licensed so I think that terminology
means to me that we would be dictating
our lenses process for registering with
the
DEA um I have a I have a recommendation
what if we change it to a regist a
registration of practitioners who have
been granted a
special you could just say requirements
for registration I think that would be
fine I think when we think of process
though we don't want to have any taking
the word process out yeah I think so
it's just it's a registration of the how
how you however you do it it doesn't
matter yeah but we want to have that
registration of the practitioners who
have been granted right so I'm just
registration of practitioners who have
been granted a special registration that
way we have and we can noodle out how
we're going to do that later but I'm I'm
going to change it for this way right
now and then we can discuss how it's
going to be done okay because I don't
want to get stuck on not that this thing
isn't important but okay we still have
80 pages to go sure okay so NSE nurse
Practice Act section 129 do we have any
concerns or questions there no concerns
until we get to section
133 okay let's let's Buzz over there
then if I can does anybody know what
page okay 133 that's only on page 41
Okay so this is relative to Temporary
licenses and I I believe the offices
version um removed this section because
temporary licenses are now under the
oplc um just wanted to note that this
should be
eliminated oh it's not part of the
practice act anymore right the board
isn't issuing temporary license the
office is so do we have this captured in
310 somewhere Mr
ound the temporary license is it All
Temporary licenses
period it's under 3106 ran numeral 5
right
yeah okay and as you recall all licenses
license approval and denials um that has
been transferred to the office thanks I
just want to make sure that it's
somewhere okay and then Section 1 134 do
we have any or 135 or
136 we have nothing until
okay yep um and then it's in Roman
numeral four oh Roman numeral four okay
that's on page 43 the office shall so
and this is another question maybe um uh
Mr osterhout could speak to it uh the
board's duties and uh powers and duties
under 326
B4 um see it it gives the board um the
power to do this periodic review of
education programs and standards um and
so when this section transfers that
power to the office it seems to conflict
uh so I just wanted to make note of that
and get get the um yours and the
office's opinion on uh whether and how
that
conflicts do you have a comment on that
Mr
O I don't think there's a conflict and
earlier in this bill we talked about
transferring and and I think it's more
consistent with the board establishing
the criteria and the office doing the
approval of the licenses and if that's
changing to education programs too which
the recommendation from the Board of
Nursing was to do and I agree with that
then I think the same would hold true
here they could set the criteria but we
could do that review and then also rely
on the subject matter experts if if
needed okay is the conflict resolved yes
okay
great one more um on in the repeal
section
I believe it's already been noted to you
but the uh repeal um relative to scope
of practice 326 b14 we're going to
that's not going to be in there and also
um the relative to
examinations that's going to that's not
going to be repealed okay and then
321a is relative to the licensed nursing
assistance correct that's staying
correct thank you that's it for nursing
okay and now um nursing home
administrators since they are
not they are still aboard right they're
not advisory is there anything that
needs to be changed here and if so can
you just give me the like you will with
the
Midwifery yes I'll I'll just give you a
great that way we don't have to go
through all that nursing
home admin
um occupational therapy is on page
47 uh there are no um changes no changes
okay
um
op oh God I can't even say that word op
dispensing uh the board Council does not
have any uh changes
for opic dispenses right Optometry
licensing anything
section one
154 um it's under Roman numeral seven
seven we're going to leave it we're not
taking that out okay that that was my
question yeah that's gonna that's going
is
um anything else to do with
Pharmacy
um just one more under Optometry section
one60
um there's a question about uh section
150 6 160 Optometry repeals okay yes
we're going to leave in relative to
penalty
we're not going to repeal
that is that what you meant is that the
concern you had or was it something else
no it was the joint credentialing
committee I I wasn't sure why this was
eliminated but um I believe it's not
been
utilized so that's why we're repealing
it I believe so yes okay so we that's
going to stay
okay all
right uh
Pharmacy one moment sorry uh there's
it's just a lengthy section so I just
want to get get I'm on 161 Pharmacy
definitions correct
um we have nothing until
172 um Roman numeral three okay 172 is
on page 54 Roman numeral the
commissioner shall adopt
rules yes um and for uh so the
commissioner shall adopt rules under RSA
541a to implement this paragraph such
rules shall include procedures for
addressing complaints and for reporting
to the Board of Pharmacy on the status
of complaints referred uh I believe that
would go to the office uh complaints are
uh reported to the office not to the
board at this at this time that was in
um last year okay so it would be such
rules include procedures for addressing
complaints and for reporting to the
office as a port to the board right I
okay all
right
um and similar comment for uh under 173
Section 1 173 yes I get it okay
okay and that is all we have for
Pharmacy okay then we can move to
physical
therapy just one question uh for
physical therapy
on in under Section
179 yep um the in other practice acts in
this amendment uh the injunctive relief
statutes have been
repealed uh and so the question is why
is this staying is it regarding title
protection um so that was the question
Mr Oster how can you rep can you answer
someone well it says RSA 328 of12 is
repealed and reenact so you want to know
why it's being
reenacted okay I it it really is for
about title protection um there are
certain statutes certain professions
have protections on their title in
particular um so I think that's the
Genesis I I agree though they don't need
instructive relief because it is already
provided for in 310
MH
okay the reflexologist section 181 was
removed from the amendment so we are
going
to speech language pathology is there
any any comments or concerns about
speech language pathology section uh yes
I do okay one moment
please and just to just so the record's
clear there were no changes for
reflexologist structural integrators and
Ag and body work therapists uh from the
board Council perspective okay um with
speech language pathology uh uh
184 there was just an editorial note to
its speech language pathology and
hearing care providers um um I just want
to make sure that is reflected that's
that's the way the the statute reads so
are you saying that 84 should be called
speech language pathology and and
hearing care providers and
hearing care providers
okay all
right and then um
section 188
yep um my understanding from the board
uh they reviewed this that uh the
reference to the sale and fitting of
hearing age should be removed from from
struck okay oh yes I see that it should
okay all
right is that it
um I believe so okay so now we're at the
New Hampshire board New Hampshire
please um there was under
197 a comment that we do need to um
discuss with the
office um regarding substantial
equivalency okay that's on page
that so 309
B6 substantial equivalency uh we just
need to consult with the office with
respect to that
section okay so you're gonna do you have
a comment Mr to have I think that's the
process we're using under 3107
anyway so the language might be a little
redundant but I don't see any
conflict why don't we just take it out
so we're going to
remove we're not going to have we're
just going to eliminate it and we're not
going to it's just going to say it's
going to be repealed and we're not going
to reenact it okay we don't need it we
don't need it in two places because
that's a problem if we have to change
something
later um is that the only comment Miss
sure yes did somebody have a question oh
you said bless you how kind that that is
all for uh the accountancy okay
love
I've
okay
Architects page 70 the bottom of page 70
are there any comments on AR
Tex um excuse me not for this bill in
the future I think there's going to be
some um changes that will need to be
made okay and why why are we saying that
in the future um it doesn't fit under
the scope of this bill okay um okay
Architects
auctioneers um auctioneers under the
scope of this bill we do not have any
changes again and that's another one in
the future okay court reporters so court
reporters still exist so we're going to
pretend that that we we're going to so
do we who's going to rewrite this
section on court reporters because I
think this was written as if it was
going to be an Advisory Board correct or
am
I no the bill proposed was to eliminate
Court repor a lure right and that failed
so I can take a look at the language but
this should be written if the cour rep
okay so Mr Oster how you're going to
look at section 218 court
reporters okay so I just want you to
know we have to exec this by next
Wednesday
so we'll talk about when because this
still has to go to OS and they're
they're finishing up this Draft
today I think you all should send them
some flowers after
that
um I'll help with the
flowers
um electricians finally electricians do
we have any so uh Elizabeth eaten board
Council for electricians um and I just
have three um areas that are being
repealed that the board uh wants to note
that shouldn't be repealed okay let me
just make sure oh that's on page um
76 oh no that's court reporters wait a
minute it's there uh section 223 it is
on page 76 okay yep so the first line um
24 a journeyman electrician shall be
employed by a master electrician uh the
board considers this to be a public
safety uh matter um there are additional
steps that a journeyman needs to take to
become a master including business
education and and other such matters uh
and the concern is that a a journeyman
will be a 1099 uh contractor with an a
master and they they think that that
relationship is in appropriate for the
supervision level required so they're
not um the next sentence I think
clarifies that by saying that each
Journeyman Electrician shall work under
the direction and supervision of a
master electrician you think that's too
loose the board wanted to well the board
I'm sorry not you personally when I see
you I'm talking about the electrician
board please the board really wanted to
tighten up that uh employer employee
relationship
okay um representative ger can I just
make a comment on that yeah I think it's
problematic and the reason is that they
have electrical corporations and they
have felt very strongly about wanting to
keep that license and the reason for
that is to allow people who are not
master electricians uh to essentially
own a corporation employ a bunch of
people which may include a master and a
journeyman the master supervises the
journeyman but the master is not the
employer so there's a conflict in the
law there and I think that that's why it
needs to be repealed in order to allow
them to have that uh that uh fun
function with respect to the electrical
corporations I think that this is
something that we need to Noodle out I
know what you're saying I understand the
board's concerned too so I don't know if
we should say journeyman shall report to
the master electrician in some other you
know I I know what you're well this is
we'll have to we'll have to talk about
this okay I'm just raising the conflict
in the law I understand I understand
sorry
sorry but I also understand what the
electricians care about which is you
know okay is that the only comment on
the from the electricians no okay um on
the next
page it's is it 319
C6 we're going to keep that no it's in
uh the section above 3195 a
319 five there's a sentence uh
eliminated the board shall maintain and
make available a list of such persons
approved for level one or level two
thirdparty electrical inspections the
board believes that this list uh being
made available is important uh so you
could change it from board to office the
office shall maintain and make available
a list of such
persons
okay and then just one more when you're
ready
okay hang on a second
um all right go ahead so you said uh 319
C6 C is staying fail we're not we're
going to keep failure to complete the
continuing education shall render the
electrician's license invalid until leny
demonstrates the board that he or she
has completed the requirement so we're
going to leave that okay okay and then
it says proof of completion shall be
sorry proof of completion shall be turns
by the board by the continuing education
provider I I do believe and and the
board um agrees that under to remove the
conflict it should be proof of
completion shall be furnished to the
raised it's it's okay to change Board
office but it's still saying continue
Prov Chang because the way it's written
is I believe now we're supposed to subm
Mr you need to speak into the microphone
because you're being this is a bit
public meeting Steve ran LIC electrician
I apologize so I just want to make sure
that it doesn't still say by the
provider because I don't think they have
a process to take that by the provider I
believe some of the Law changes or rule
changes we're making the electrician
submit it now so we just want to make
sure that's clear is it still going to
going to be by the provider or is it
going to be by the lensey that is
submitted that's
all okay we had a third party software
have provider C Circus Circus circled so
I'll um license see I'll make myself a
note and we'll check it out thank you
for
that okay you can come you can come back
so are we done with electricians now
um Family Family
mediators that is staying right we
didn't make that
advisory so is there someone that is
going to go through that and make sure
2:30
okay
234 yes what uh just give me one moment
I
sure so there's supposed to be another
subcommunity meeting at 10:30 in this
room but is going to happen after this
because we're going to keep going on
this we're almost done done there um
section um 234 uh
Foresters
um I believe um I'm sorry I'm reading
one I think there was some uh
legislation pending on this one um this
is our other board counsel right we're
not going to do anything with them we're
going to leave them alone okay so does
that mean that this has to test to
change um no I believe this should be
fine
okay you've got until Friday to tell me
it isn't
okay um so we're going to skip Foresters
and then we're going
to Guardian at
lium are there any changes to
that
if not uh one moment please
yep we're not going to do anything with
Guardian M lium at the moment okay um so
this
p82 uh Guardian ad item um page 82 line
n it says second half of that sentence
the issuance of a license by the board
shall be evidence that the person named
on okay I'm sorry what section are you
on um page 82 section 238 line
nine I have that's
Foresters is that what you mean did you
say I mean Foresters okay Foresters okay
um the yeah what line the issuance of a
license by the board oh okay it should
be
office
okay all right thank you Guardian Liam
um Mr Simon if you need to leave I'm
talking if if you need to leave we can
address your concerns after this you're
um did this legislation conflict now
because this was tentatively to be an
Advisory board but it's not going to be
now
so do you want to take a look at it
separately
or there were some items as written that
were noted okay um
so section
243 yes
um under Roman
numeral
to the new e it was
G um the new e yes which is gather such
information concerning applicants for
certification as well ass this um courts
to make an form decision on whether or
not to appoint an individual as guardian
at lium in in a particular case um I
don't know that that is necessarily a
board function so much as an office
function um as it pertains to uh
receiving information about applications
and applicants
okay I'll check with the office on that
sure and a similar comment to the new f
okay any other questions on Guardian
for um so for uh section 245 under the
repeals of Roman numeral 2 there was a
question um regarding whether or not um
if this would be replaced with anything
um it's 490
C five Roman numeral 2 e um relative to
resignation I think we need to look at
this section in more detail okay so
we'll do that sure
um can I yes
um do you think we should postpone the
meeting on 1622 because this is looks
like it's going to take a while well I
don't know
1622 oh 1622 isn't that is that the one
that we're doing together oh that's your
bill are we gon can we do it after
this just spoken to the folks in just
okay we're gonna we're almost done with
this I think we're going to keep going
and we're gonna okay I just wanted to
check that thank you thank you okay
excuse me before we move on um top of
page 85 uh certification issued by the
geologists um uh just a grammatical
change
um section
247 uh Roman numeral
one um
H uh just need to add an and at the
after the
semicolon and I believe it was it was
I
okay
geologist okay because then we're going
to do home inspectors yep uh it would be
um Roman um sorry section
253 y uh line 14 um I believe
um by presenting evidence satisfactory
to the board should be to the office uh
no I think it's
um presenting uh
evidence uh related to uh criteria
board okay making a determination in
compliance with criteria established by
inspectors um I
believe want to get the section number
for
you um section number
256 mhm um under Roman
numeral
four um the board shall have the
discretion to reject they believe that
should be that power is vested with the
office um to it should change to the
office shall have a discretion to reject
okay um section
257 um
I believe again uh there's board
approved
course um I believe it's uh courses
approved by the office
um are you talking about line
15 um I believe it starts on 14 and
says continuing education completion in
each two-year renewal period of a
minimum of 20 hours of continuing educ a
shall be required for license rural
provided that one hour of the 20
required hours shall be from a board
approved course on appropriate building
regulations
including uh any recent revisions to
regulations and I believe the office
would be approving yes those courses so
would be an office approved course with
criteria right I have the
office um based with off sorry the the
office using board criteria shall
approve education courses yes okay
right
yeah why is the office approving them
and not the
board I think the board should have the
say we're getting a little too far out
of what the intent of the office was
when it was
created
boards are supposed to still
remain on their own in the functions of
what the criteria are for
licensing while the board while the
office itself can
handle the functions I still think it's
the board who should be
approving
what is required for the licensing they
have the expertise they have the
knowledge they're the ones in the field
and I think we're taking that away from
them with some of this language are
changing in here and I have an issue
with that and I know I'm not part of the
subcommittee man chair but no you I just
want to State my concerns over as we're
going through this and that's why I'm
here right well the issue with uh then
we have to have a whole philosophical
discussion on that because this is
consistent with everything else that
we've
done and I guess it's something that we
need to talk about it is because I think
representative Schmidt was here from in
the beginning when oplc was given what
they were and it was this wasn't the
intent as far as we're going here from
okay
yes thank you madam chair and thank you
representative Goldie for your remarks
uh I I se absolutely second that and the
intent was always that the oplc was
going to be the admin administrative
underpinning of the operation but the
substance of the board's expertise which
is the professional the scope of
practice all aspects in relating to the
profession itself that was going to
remain the board and it was never Our
intention and we've discussed this for
years that we we were afraid that the
oplc was being given the executive
director was being given authority to to
exercise oversight and control of the
substance of the
profession was never intended to do that
and it and and we didn't and the senior
members of the committee who had seen
this whole Evolution we never wanted
that and we've been discussing that
amongst ourselves for years that we did
not want to have that lost sight of so I
I absolutely second what representative
goalie is saying and I believe that you
were
acknowledging that that is a discussion
that we on the committee need to have
and that was one of the reasons that we
voted inim study on 1676 if you recall
because we wanted to use that as a
vehicle to to accomplish this purpose of
getting
oplc focused on on the administrative
end of things um and U and so I I wholly
support what represented has just said
okay well that said I don't want to be
seem like I'm I'm callous about this but
at the same time I'm we're I'm printing
under a deadline and we're going to get
this bloody thing done so we're on Manu
and we're going to talk about it
separately because that's a whole
different that's a whole different
philosophy than what we talked about in
this committee and I understand the um
the discussion and although it's nice
that the senior members were talking
about this together you know now that
it's here we need to discuss it publicly
and we aren't going to do that today um
manufactured housing I think we're
taking this out
surveyors um I think the there's a
question um under Section
uh
273 Roman numeral 3 that's been struck
if the uh land surveyor and training um
is being removed is that your comment
comment it was all
removed
yeah
okay so they're concerned about land
surveyor and training correct being
struck that's correct the comment I
right um I
will I'll recognize that
concern um and and then if that is a
case that it is
removed uh
then
likely I
apologize section 274 Roman numeral
2B if the land surveyor in training is
being
eliminated um then that that reference
in that section would just need to be
removed right or we're going to keep it
in if we keep the land surveyor in
correct okay
um the language in the opinion of the
board um
this appears to contemplate that the
boore would be reviewing the
license uh
however it's it the uh licensing goes
through the
office you mean the whole
section um in the opinion
board yes if you could just strike in
the opinion of the
board
okay
thank
you I
may anything else not for land surveyors
land Landscape Architects Landscape
Architects
um uh section
um it's uh line 36 I believe um
31a 154 expiration all licenses issued
by the board I believe it should be
reference to issued by the office
yes um and that should be all for
Landscape
Architects
okay
um mechanical licenses just one uh note
it is in section
290 section
290 and Roman numeral 3 okay just a
291 yes ranal three yes so this has um
the board with an affirmative vote of at
least four of the appointed board
members and then skipping the line that
was crossed out it says and with the
approval of the executive director of
The Office of professional license shur
and certification shall adopt rules uh I
the board is questioning whether with
the approval of the executive director
is required or okay thank you yep that's
it all right and then
um Natural
Sciences
uh natural scientists um just a concern
about
um section
292 yep uh Roman numeral three uh the
last
line uh study your education credits
acceptable to the board um before being
allowed to proceed with the
examination
um it it might be better to put uh
should it should
beeria established by the board
board and that would be all for uh that
section
okay real estate appraisers no changes
uh from board counsel
perspective
okay real estate Practice Act real
estate Practice Act um
section 302 Roman
C3 um I believe uh it should be proves
to the
commission is that I'm sorry can you
read the whole sentence what uh what
it's States now is proves the to the
commission that the applicant yes and um
if we're following in line with um
what's being done here it would be
proofs to the office based on criteria
commission or criteria established by
the
commission
okay all
right
any other questions any other concerns
on the real estate Practice Act uh yes
um
same section
305 Roman numeral 2 Section 305 Roman
numeral 2 yes
um it should say uh and satisfy all
require re Ms established by the
541a
um again um section
there's a few references 30 back to
302 uh Roman
numeral section 302 yep Roman numeral
2 um I have let me just try to find
section
302 okay I believe it's page 105 yep
G um Smith evidence of at least six
separate real estate transactions in
which the applicant was actively
involved and was compensated or proved
to the
office based on criteria established by
the commission that the applicant has
equivalent
experience that may be worded better
okay
but that's is the uh all right thank you
else uh one moment
yes I I'm not sure if this was uh fixed
in an updated copy uh but section
[Music]
305 Roman numeral three we just did that
one right Roman numeral three
yes it says the
office instead of the commission the
office May establish a fee yes yes that
okay and that's all I have for uh the
Real Estate Commission okay we are
taking out the septic system
evaluators that's being removed from
this bill completely
okay and then I think think that's
it thank you those are all the comments
from U thank thank you thank you I want
to thank everyone for being here and
working so hard on this and
um we'll keep you updated on any public
hearings or subcommittee work on this so
I'd like to close the if there's is
there anyone else that wants to speak
about this because if
not I'm going to close the um
subcommittee on this and we're going to
Bill
1622 and I think representative shuid is
going to take over for a little while
how's
that representative mire
I'm just going to go see if
representative Maguire wants to discuss
her
Amendment
representative Maguire to discuss her
proposed amendment number
H this is at the request
of and in the words of the
administrative rules office and um I
think you should ask ask them to talk
about it it's not really
my
initiative so um I'll recognize Mr moral
to
speak good morning Michael moral
director of administrative rules in
OS um with me is attor uh Comm Attorney
Kim reev she uh I think you all should
have received an email a day or two ago
uh regarding this bill I think it was
sent out to everybody on
Edna and uh which Kim had drafted
um I think I'm going to start out going
for that but Kim is more knowledgeable
on it so I'll let her take
over uh I'm just gonna start I'm
sorry
um our memo had divided the uh Bill up
into uh three parts those that uh think
we uh we think are most important uh
that would improve oiless rules function
those that uh we believe four five and
11 are housekeeping
amendments uh improving ORS rules
function was sections 3 9 10 and
12 um sections 1 two 4 and 6 through 8
um we're not taking a position on
whether the committee retains those
not
go okay so um I guess I'll start with um
looking at our memo here that we sent a
couple of days ago um so section three
um the amendments there um we're
proposing those because they would
improve the certification process in 541
a151
um I hope that the uh the bullet points
there or the numbering there those those
areas kind of explain what we're doing
currently the agency files an adopted
rule then we edit and create revision
and Source notes and then that draft
rule draft certified rule is s over to
the agency and the agency has 121 days
to respond and then after um that 121
days um OS then works with the agency
and gets that certified rule up on the
website the problem is is that although
agencies have a statutory deadline of
120 days to respond and to certify their
rules that isn't being met and because
sometimes they're taking more than six
months to certify the rules then that
means that um what's currently posted on
our website is not not an accurate um
it's not an accurate rule in some cases
so even though the rule has been you
know um approved and has been adopted
and is effective what's on our website
um could be old it could be you know a
year old or more so um if you look in
the second part there the future
certification that kind of describes our
amendments so first the agency would
file an adopted rule with us then we
would post that as f rule on our website
under the appropriate agency then we
would take time to edit create the
revision notes and update the source
notes and then that draft certified rule
would be sent to the agency and we would
give them 60 days to let us know whether
or not that looks right if there are any
changes but um the important piece is if
you look at number six is that after 60
days with or without a response from the
agency the rule would be certified and
that way we could go ahead and get it up
on our website so that um describes
essentially what we're doing and uh I
know there was some concern that uh it
looked like there were just semantic
changes to the statute but they're not
so they would help us um get those rules
posted
earlier representative Maguire did you
have a question I have a question yes do
I understand it correctly that right now
you have no time limit at all
no that's not correct um there is a time
limit like I said the statute says
there's 121 days for the agency to
certify those rules no no this is for
you to if I read it correctly you edit
the rule and so forth yeah and in this
case it this the the revision gives you
180 day deadline yeah so current yeah
currently my understanding is that we
have a backlog of around four months and
so so so we we wanted to give ourselves
a bit more time just in case we got
slammed uh with a lot of certified rules
um there is some wiggle room there I
mean we would be agreeable to changing
you know that timeline right now we do
try to get those um revision and Source
notes and the editing work done within
that 120 days and back out to the agency
um but Mike has been here a lot longer
than me and speak to um that process how
it's been working in the past okay um as
Kim had referenced I I think the
important part of this section is that
as she said currently you could have a
rule that's in effect but it's not
published on our website for six months
maybe even a year under the changes we
would as soon as possible after the
agency adopts and files a rule with our
our office we would put that on the
website and it would be just as adopted
uh we won't have gone through the
process with the agency of putting in
Source notes and making sure all their
eyes are dotted and tees across but this
has been a problem both with the public
and with agencies we've had several
times just in the last year where
agencies have put in a um a
rule gone through a new Ru making to
amend existing rules without realizing
they had already done so the previous
year they were looking back at the prior
rule which might have been five or eight
years old and the same thing happens
with the public they will call us and
say this rule says this but the agency's
doing that well it turns out yes the
agency adopted a new rule eight eight
months ago and uh so they were doing
what the rule says but the public
looking on our website did not see
it
okay so
so under this process you'll post it
almost
immediately with
a um with with some kind of
expected we would indicate that it's you
know the adopted and effective ruled as
filed so by the agency so there would be
that little disclaimer there but like I
said uh you know once we've done our
work with you know creating the source
notes and revision notes and sometimes
that can take a while too if there have
been many changes um you know if there's
been like movement between you know uh
taking one chapter moving it to another
those revision and Source notes can be
kind of lengthy so it could take some
time but anyway yeah the rule would be
posted almost
immediately which is a good thing
because I I know I've looked for a rule
that I know was approved by jel car and
there good thank you madam
chair okay um so then the next part um
sections nine and 10 would extend the
final proposal and conditional approval
of request deadlines that are currently
in the statute and I'll just read from
the bullet points here um it would
change the filing deadline for final
proposals from 21 days before the
monthly meeting to 30 days it would
change a conditional approval request
from 7 days before the meeting to 10
days before the meeting it would create
a filing deadline for amended
conditional approval request that
address substantive comments of five
days before the meeting it would
prohibit the late filing of amended
conditional approval requests pass that
deadline by stating that no waivers will
be granted and it would eliminate the
filing of revised conditional approval
request unless they are filed during the
meeting the reason why we are proposing
these is that we are being responsive to
committee members concerns they often
state that with the number of proposals
on the agenda that they do not always
have enough time to review those so our
hope is that by shifting this deadline
up a bit we can actually review and get
those items posted on our website
earlier so that the committee members
will have more time to see them
like I said um right now the the agenda
can have around 30 proposals and um we
do work with the agencies and a lot of
those will go on consent but some of the
other ones won't so you know we could
have anywhere from 10 to 15 to 20 that
could be on the regular agenda it's kind
of you know it's proposal specific right
so we don't really know but like I said
our hope is that we would get those
posted sooner and um we were also hoping
that we would eliminate some of this
extraneous filings and what I mean is
that sometimes the agencies don't always
have great Version Control and so
sometimes say you know um the committee
conditionally you know say they file a
conditional approval request and then we
take a look at it and we make comments
we send that back to them and then they
realize that they need to file a revised
amended conditional approval request and
they do that
but instead of using their conditional
approval request they use an older
document well then it comes in and we've
now have a ton of more comments on it um
that can happen um the other thing that
could happen is that uh sometimes they
are um filing uh amended conditional
approval request only to address
editorial comments and not substantive
comments and um as you can imagine with
that many proposals coming in
with us reviewing them that kind of
takes a lot of time on us to review
those when we could be looking at
substantive substantive issues on other
proposals so um like I said we were were
doing this in order to have more time
for the committee members to be able to
review these proposals um the late filed
items that could be filed during the
meeting um Jael car rules do allow for
that um they would to meet the
requirements of the Jael car rule which
is that they mostly resolve all the
issues within the proposal and so um we
are hoping that with this that we'll
kind of you we'll get a better product
we'll have less filings that aren't
substantive that are only editorial and
um like I said the main thing was trying
to get these proposals in front of the
committee members at an earlier period
of time if you think about it now with
the um
with the deadlines you know if we take a
couple of weeks to review a final
proposal and send that back or if it
takes a week or however long and uh then
the agency files and sometimes they are
filing conditional approval request the
very last minute three or four days
before the meeting that doesn't give the
a that doesn't give the members enough
time to review that proposal so that's
the reason why for this
amendment thank you representative
Schmidt did you have a
question thank you madam chair uh and
you've been speaking to uh the concern
that I wanted to to address uh more
fully here uh I I understand the the
completely the idea of the moving
forward the of the or back whichever way
you want to consider that um of these
deadlines and so forth but since the the
administ admin administrative rules
units eyes are in some cases uh the last
set of eyes that see things because if
they're going to go on the consent
calendar I mean any one of the Jael cars
as those of us who are on the Jael car
know we can pull it off but if you put
it on the on the on the consent calendar
because in your professional opinion the
rule meets all the criteria for approval
um then we're not going to pull it off
just so we can redo your work uh but in
those
cases your eyes are really the def
definitive and your expertise not just
your eyes obviously uh the definitive uh
decisionmaking
um capacity uh to get the rules right
and I really have a problem with the
idea that things can get rushed and they
don't get sufficiently vetted um so uh
is is it some things are easy to see you
can see that this is simple no problem
and and you can effectively rubber stamp
it because it is right in other
situations it may be and it frequently
is um more subtle and it really needs to
be thought about and that needs time so
are you going to have a way
of pulling back from uh the commitment
to get it done quickly if you see that
it's not going to get vetted properly if
if it's done
quickly well I think we we definitely do
I mean if you think about it we get an
IP in and sometimes we get draft
versions in and I was thinking about
this recently sometimes I could
review the same rule 8 to 10 times in
anyone rule making if the agency decides
that they're going to send us a draft IP
or a draft final proposal so I think we
do take some time I think the the issue
is making sure that these get posted
early enough you know we as we go
through them the final proposals they
are um uploaded to our website in a
meeting packet form for committee review
you know for committees members to
review and so our hope is that you know
by reviewing these shifting that
deadline up then th that those items
will be posted a little earlier you know
in the process and uh thereby giving the
committee members more time to review I
do think committee members are reviewing
proposals and they do review the ones
that are on consent because we do
sometimes have committee members pull
them off of consent um we do discuss
items with the chair and vice chair when
we're not sure whether or not an item
can go on consent um so we we do that as
well I hope that answers the
question okay well thank you for that I
I mean obviously it's the sooner that we
can get our hands on things to start
looking at them the better it is the
question is that whether it's being done
sufficiently intensively on on on subtle
things where you have to think about it
whether this is really going to work
because the rules have to work
otherwise it's like just saying well
just jump up there and dunk that ball
and say I'm in a wheelchair I can't dunk
anymore well I would say that um you
know all proposed get more than one
review so um you know I'll get the final
proposal in we'll review that I'll send
that over to Mike he will review it and
then I'll review it again so um I don't
envisioning that process changing at all
so we'll still be doing that work so it
will have more than one review very good
chair representative groda thank you um
I take it because your Amendment deals
with additions to the bill as opposed to
comments about the bill itself that you
have no comment on
that okay I'm I'm I'm looking at
sections in the original bill yeah we
have section two which talks about oplc
oh if you look down representative groa
so I was just going to cover the items
that were of importance to op OLS
operation
first all right so um the the next
section which is on page two of our uh
our memorandum here is on um it would
Amendment it would amend um RSA 541 a19
C that's uh section 12 of the bill and
uh this would allow the gel car to
conditionally approved expedited
revisions of forms so this is another
substantive Amendment and um we were
recommending this one based on feedback
that we have received and just um what
we have experienced
um in this process so the um expedited
revisions to forms the
xrfs um right now there's not um the
statute doesn't permit an agency to file
a conditional approval request for that
and we have encountered situations in
which the agency did need to make
changes and so this would allow for that
to happen otherwise they would have to
get a preliminary objection or they
would have to withdraw entirely so um
that was the reason for this one and it
would also allow the um the Jael car
committee to um to object to the rule if
that the forms are Incorporated in so
that was the reason for that Amendment
the um the next one section four 5 and
11 those are housekeeping amendments um
they um the first one in section 4 it um
let's see it's the deadline to respond
what we were doing here is um making it
so that a board doesn't have to file a
conditional approval and adoption on the
same day so that's the purpose for for
this amendment and then uh five and 11
remove out ofate references and an
incorrect
citation yeah go and just to clarify um
your references to um sections 10 11 and
12 refer to the proposed
amendment thank you yes sections 9
through 12 are um part of the amendment
um regarding U section 4 um amending 54
A1
1910 um part of this is because right
now if an agency doesn't expedite
revision form
I'm I'm sorry we're talking interim
rules interim rule process as most of
you know is a uh quickened process by
which an agency can adopt a rule right
away there are only specific reasons
such as the Rule's already expired or is
about to expire or the court has made a
decision that affects the rule Etc um
right now everyone whether you're a
board of commission or whether you're an
agency has the same deadline to file um
a response to the for the interim role
where there's a conditional approval and
that is very short I 14 days I think
it's 14 days a lot of boards and
commissions only meet once a month some
of them only meet quarterly so in order
to meet this deadline they often have to
get a waiver uh from the director of
legislative services in order to uh
extend that deadline this would
problem thank
you so um the remainder like um director
moral said um we did make these
recommendations um we're not taking a
position on the retention of those
sections we made those recommendations
um mostly because in in response to gel
car committee concerns um section one
would require a rulle making requirement
on the opl C's retention policy um I
won't go through all of this um we do
note that um you know the committee
could opt to create a carveout you know
for ruem for the oplc for this retention
schedule um if you look there in the
subsequent paragraphs um the Department
of State Division of archives and
Records management has the
responsibility of um of maintaining
State records and um they do have Ru
making authority to establish guidelines
but the rules expired in 1990 and so
there are no established guidelines and
um our uh position has been that the
retention policy clearly Falls
underneath the definition of a rule
meaning that it needs to go through the
541a process so if the committee
disagrees with that or feels that it
should not go through the ru making
process you could always do a uh you
know you could do a carve out from 541a
for it and this provides the um the
rationale for why we you know why we
made the recommendation based on
committee
concerns okay now I forgot what it
say um as Kim said we believe that uh
setting up a retention policy in a rule
is necessary because it it is a rule it
affects people outside the agency the
public may want to know well how long
are they going to keep this record um
most boards uh and agencies do have
retention schedules it'll say something
like shall retain all records for a
period of three years and otherwise un
less otherwise uh dictated by the
director of archives
um we think that's very important for
people to know I some of the bigger
agencies have more than one retention um
rule because it depends on sometimes the
statutes require a certain period
sometimes it's a different type of
program and the retention period may
longer can I just ask what is the
issue if it's since it shows up every
time there's a question about it and we
keep getting nagged about it I'd like to
either put in a clear requirement or
just say they don't it doesn't need to
be a rule we need to decide one way or
the other
and if the director of archives has let
his rules lapse for 35 years I'd say we
may not need to go through Ru
making personally but I'm willing to to
subcommittee we we are not sure how much
of a burden this would place on oplc
because they cover over 50 boards some
are advisory boards some are governing
boards I don't know if they would
anticipate having to have different
retention periods for different boards
it could be burdensome on that but uh I
think they would be better able to speak
thank you we'll we have Mr Oster out
thinks I guess I'm I'm just um chatting
with um I shouldn't be chatting I do
think that the idea of record
retention did come up in previous
hearings on o with with oplc so if you
can recall Mr O to have what that
discussion was you we could use a
two I I can tell you that when this came
before gel car they did not object on
that
basis yeah that that's correct the
committee did not object on that basis
so and I believe they did get a copy of
the Excel spreadsheet that outlined um
the retention policy right so on um the
next would you like to hear from
attorney a to help now okay yes I think
around morning Douglas ooster how is it
morning good morning Douglas
OPC
um I mean I think I think our stance has
been pretty clear that I don't think we
need a special carve out for adopting
the Secretary of State's rules um I do
remember at Jael car when we had the the
conversation the executive director
testified there was no objection and I I
believe it was Senator Lang made a
comment to the effect of we're holding
the wrong agency responsible for for
this uh I tend to agree agree with that
statement I think if if the committee
decides uh rules need to be done I don't
think I I don't think this language is
is the way it should be done we do have
the policy in place um to address
director Mor's question I don't think we
we we've got our spreadsheet but I I
that sort of covers everything um but
it's not really a different policy um or
practice of keeping records sent over to
archives another concern is addressing
archives and I don't know the interplay
between if we have the rules adopted and
there's conflicts with Secretary of
State rules or archiving or I'm not
really sure what the expectation is
there as far as are we are we expected
to set up sort of our own archival
system separate and distinct from
Secretary of State and every other
agency I I don't know if that's the
intention or what that means um so that
that is our stance that
I
representative
Schmid thank you mam chair so as you as
some of us are aware we have a new
archist okay um uh and she was before
this committee uh relatively recently uh
and so and she's in the process of
reviewing a lot of stuff that may have
been to some degree Gathering dust for a
while but because she's looking at
things in uh a new uh I think we should
reach out to her and uh and try and
coordinate things as well as possible
because it's clear that we uh that we we
we don't want to have stuff sitting
around in the archives that has no
longterm value by the Same by the same
token we also don't want to have
completely lost touch with it where you
going like it's kind of like the checks
from 30 years ago they must be around
here someplace but uh I don't know where
that place place is and it may take me a
couple years to find them or I could
stumble ac across them tomorrow looking
for something else but we we need to
have a more uh flexible system but also
one that is in touch with reality so I
think the fact that we have a new
archivist looking at things um and and
evaluating things and making changes as
well is beneficial if we work together
with her thank
you representative uire in response to
that and the information I suggest that
we delete section
one and let the state archist figure out
what what should be done
and
um the statute already requires the
office to maintain official records in
accordance with their retention
policy that should be good enough unless
the the archivist comes up with
something different we I think that
you're they're totally correct that if
the archist has the responsibility for
rules for that we don't want to have two
conflict can I just ask does does that
agreeable
to
Mike moral again uh yes that that would
be fine and I would be willing to uh try
to facilitate a meeting with Secretary
of State Andor the new director along
with Douglas or other representative
from oplc to discuss uh rulemaking with
them thank you that would be great um
I'm I'm guessing we are not going to
exact this until the 13 is that that is
correct so um yeah I'm not sure if we'll
have another subcommittee meeting but if
we can hear from you if we need to make
further changes thank you okay perhaps
that on on section two which has to do
with
oplc license
renewals I think what they're trying to
do is they're trying to
clarify um
what
licenses I don't know if we need that
because we are I mean it's in statute
years the reason why we made the
recommendation is because many of the
board statutes have not yet been amended
to remove this conflict so the oplc
statute
3108 I think section two says that they
will expire two years from the date of
issuance correct but there are other
board stat statutes that say that they
will expire in the lenses birth month so
then rather than recommend that every
statute be amended we recommended this
language so that that conflict could be
ignored okay so we're going to leave it
in okay thank you that that Mr Rous is
that your your
suggestion I mean if we could do another
100 page Bill next year two I'd really
rather
not uh no one comment I do have is under
540 or no HP
518 we did change the definition of
license so that it comports with um
541a in RSA 310 so we could probably
just m change the language to all
licenses and then we wouldn't need to
identify registration certifications R
all the other things that would be my
only suggestion on that piece okay all
questions I was going to say the the
rest of the um the bill sections six
seven um let me see here six seven and
eight kind of all go hand inand um
section six uh We've made this
recommendation in response to Jael car
committee concerns about the enforcement
of expired rules um 541a is pretty
explicit that agencies are not to
enforce expired rules but um we have
been encountering that a lot and so um
we made this recommendation in response
to that concern so um section six would
allow the court U marac County Superior
Court if the court so chooses to Levy a
financial penalty upon an agency for
enforcing an expired rule again that is
if the C court so chooses to do so um if
they were if the court was asked to
issue a declaratory judgment on an
expired rule so um you know an expired
rule is no longer law it doesn't matter
what the rule was governing um it can't
be enforced and like I said uh we are
encountering situations in which the
rules have been enforced um the other
two sections seven and eight are also
about the enforcement of expired rules
um the seven is around the refunding it
would require agencies to refund fines
and fees collected on that expired rule
so um like I said
you know the statute is pretty clear
that agencies should not be enforcing
expired rules for any purpose and so
this would basically um direct the
agencies to refund any fees or fines
that they collected on an expired role
um Section 8 um would uh require the
agencies to file an additional report
and they already have to file a report
with their final proposal outlining
stakeholder comments and how they
considered those comments so this would
be uh in addition to that report it
would um basically outline what
enforcement actions they have taken
pursuant to the expired Rule and it
would specifically require them to
include whether or not any fines or fees
were assessed and whether or not they
have been refunded so that in in an
Essence is what these three sections are
about representative Maguire yes this is
a question that that the Jael car has
been asking on every rule that comes
before them that was expired and the
agencies generally have the response
it'll say it will this change will
simply put that response into the
permanent record of the rule be because
it'll be part of the final package and I
I think we need that regardless of any
uh M Mr moral thank you I would like to
note that uh oplc is uh by and large an
exception to this uh frequently when
they become be come before Jael car they
know that there's an expired Rule and
they will look without asking by the
committee whether or not it's been
enforced whether any fines have been
imposed uh Etc and they have even gone
to the step of returning fees that were
collected uh under expired
rules I I would add that this that the
underlying issue is enforcement of those
expired rules uh the process we've laid
out here in six seven and 8 may not be
the best there may be others that would
work better but it was just an idea how
to address this
situation and one other thing to note is
that um you know the fines and fees are
often not set by Statute the agency is
directed to establish those in
administrative role so if the rule
expires well then there's no authority
to collect those fines and fees and um
Dr Mor is correct in that oplc actually
goes you know beyond you know what we
normally see by the agencies and that
they often do come prepared to discuss
that enforcement and um then they also
you know already go ahead and refund so
so we were thinking that the impact
might be minimal but we don't know and
like director moral said um there could
be a better way to go about this but
recommended sounds fair representative
schi thank you madam chair for uh there
are several of of course as you know are
on the jela car currently um but for
members of the public or other people
who are not at the jail car meetings uh
on a regular basis uh the the reality is
that this expired rule situation is one
that is very meticulously uh adhered to
uh with regard to jel car meetings when
an item comes up that relates to an
expired rule uh it is it is meticulously
reported on it in in every instance uh
and the chair generally questions uh
what the what the agent agcy has been
doing on on this Rule and the report is
that we haven't been enforcing it and
and and and it's I just want to make
sure that everybody that's not there on
a regular basis knows that that this is
being adhered to very
very meticulous is the right word very
meticulously because we take it
seriously that an expired rule is not a
rule it's a null
thank
you any other comments thank you very
much for your input um so at this point
I would ask representative Maguire as
the prime sponsor and the uh purported
sponsor of the amendment if you'd be
willing to redraft your Amendment um
it'll obviously take a renumbering with
the deletion of section one uh would you
be willing to take that that
on the revised Amendment will delete
section
one reward section two slightly to
Simply say all
licenses and I think that's the only
change okay and then um I that require
ruming of the rest of your Amendment
thank you very much yeah we'll we'll do
it that way okay yes I I can do that
thank
you um is that all um okay I don't think
we can actually vote on the amendment at
this point but um does the subcommittee
feel that we need to take a vote on the
amendment or are you okay with just
presenting it uh at the next
exec I
think I think if we have the amendment
we can meet just prior to when we EX
second and do a quick vote to make it
official okay yeah I'm good with that I
will distribute the amendment okay to
the sub committee as soon as I get it
you do I have a motion to
adjourn thank you second second thank
you all for your attendance and uh for
your important
submissions so there will be an exact
session starting at 1:30 we'll have a
republican caucus in here at 1 I presume
there will be a Democrat Caucus
somewhere
else um I'm I'm just asking too do you
have an idea what time the exec is going
to be on the
13th we're starting first thing in the
morning I think it's 10 o'clock on the
it we've already scheduled couple of
bills that's what's in the calendar 10
it's in the calendar okay so we'll we'll
put the subcommittee
like 9:30 or something to something like
you
this this is our executive session on
about half the remaining
bills uh I will not be going in order
and committee reports are due as soon as
possible and no later than 10 o'clock
Monday morning at the latest so if
deadline
okay and we
have I think representative gr is still
talking to OS about
okay so I'd like to start with House
Bill
1387 on the State Building Code and I
move ought to pass and present
H
second
you should it was passed
one we wouldn't want that to happen to
the all right so I I'll mentioned this
amendment simply
changes the timing for uh when the
building code review board updates a
starts review of a
code it was set at two years and this
amendment makes it one year because we
now require legislative confirmation of
the changes before they go into effect
so this is wait a year have it reviewed
and then have it approved by the
legislation and it's going to be at
least two years before you get through
that process so this simply allows the
board to start their review a little
sooner on some of them uh it it is
essentially the same effect as as
current law and I hope you will support
it representative
I think well said and I think that
was actually asked for too by the board
as well 12 you're right it
was yes Madam chair yes I'll just add as
chair of the subcommittee this was
requested by the board and very simple
change the committee was in agreement
but we did not have the amendment before
us so the subcommittee is in favor of it
but we did not vote on it thank you okay
anyone else have comments questions
about the
amendment
all right seeing
none the motion is to adopt amendment
0813 to House Bill 1387 and the clerk
can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Sasso yes
representative Dolan yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative
Gro is in here when the question was
called yes you were
yes you weren't here when the motion was
made but you were here when the question
was called good yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes representative
SEL yes representative Davis yes
representative Lane yes representative
Gould yes representative Smith yes
representative Manti yes and the chair
yes 19 yay zero
n
okay and I move ought to pass with
Amendment for House Bill
second okay I have nothing more to say
this is a minor technical corrections to
the process of updating building codes
repres
goie well said
concerns okay seeing none the clerk can
call the rooll representative Simon yes
representative lakus yes representative
Bailey yes representative Sasso yes
representative Dolan
yes clerk vot yes representative Boyd
yes representative Brown yes
representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative selig yes
representative Davis yes representative
Lane yes representative
Gould yes representative Smith yes
representative
mapy yes and the chair yes 19 y z n all
consent all right we put that one on
consent
interesting okay representative M py you
1285 I move to
itl um
1285 okay is representative Le a seconds
do you wish to speak to your motion
thank you madam uh speak Madam speaker
sorry Madame chair um this makes more
sense not to do it right now with uh all
the um Podiatry meets once in three
months there's and the Board of Medicine
meets every month so to add more to the
podiatric U member of the board to meet
every month uh doesn't make sense and
it's functioning well if it's in broken
don't fix it so that's with that I say
we don't
merge
okay likeus yeah um I agree the the
other point is that um it's it's not
clear they would uh fit together too
well I mean the doctors the podiatrists
are have some conflict um there is an
issue that uh there aren't that many
podiatrists so it is a a small
profession it might make sense in the
future to turn it into an Advisory board
but doing the merger I don't think is
okay Schmid you have a comment no just I
I agree that it's not appropriate to
merge these two boards okay excellent
anyone
else okay the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1285 and the
clerk can call the role representative
Simon yes representative Lakers yes
representative Bailey yes representative
santonastaso yes representative Dolan
yes representative gearhard yes clerk
votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative selig yes
representative Davis yes representative
Lane yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
M JY yes and the chair yes 20 a0 a okay
any objections to
consent okay seeing none we'll put that
consent all right and I'm going to move
in expedient to legislate on House Bill
1190 is there a
second
and this is the interstate social work
licensure compact it's well-intentioned
but I'm convinced it's unconstitutional
and therefore I I can't recommend it and
Simon um yeah for those reasons I also
had some um some concerns about uh the
Dynamics that might uh create state to
state um and it didn't seem like it was
going to help some of the concerns that
were being brought for by the soci
workers as well um I I just as a general
rule I
have a problem setting up these quas
governmental agencies that have the
power to somewhat oversee themselves uh
and the fact that they could pass a law
that's binding on the state of New
Hampshire uh that we would have to be
reactionary to that we wouldn't have say
on that before it went into effect but
we'd have to react to it uh to me I
think is also unconstitutional so um for
those reasons I I can't support it I I
agree though I I the concept is fine but
I can't agree with the compact itself
all right anyone else representative
manuti I will not be open uh voting itl
on this I think it's a critical piece at
this point when you're facing so much um
shortage with the mental health
providers and uh uh it's before the
covid itself we had the Mental Health
crisis and it was overshadowed by the
pandemic and now you know we are facing
it even more so to say this is not it's
not the answer for everything but at
least it is the right one of the tools
that can be in the toolbox for mental
health providers so I cannot support the
itl this okay representative leus I
agree with uh with the other person made
the motion and seconded the other only
thing I'd say is that um I mean it's too
bad it structured this way if it was
done in a way that the the board of the
compact could propose rules but they
would not go into effect until ratified
by the legislator legislators that
wanted to or the states that wanted to I
would have been fine with this okay
anyone else representative
Smith thank you madam chair just a a
thought um right now we do have critical
shortages in the areas that we're
talking about this be Ed could there be
a set time for this to work and then it
has to be relooked at and at that point
could be it or tabled or whatever and
not go any further could could we set a
time on this can unfortunately it has to
be voted out of this committee by the
end of the month and this isn't quite at
the deadline but it's not far from it
okay and the other point is that a
feature of these compacts is that every
state has to adopt the exact same
language we can't modify it okay all
right thank you okay represent
goalie thank you madam chair and I too
will support the itl um one of the main
reasons like you said is boilerplate
language I don't think we should have to
follow that and be held to it um second
is when we heard in testimony from
all the social workers that they'd be
able to follow
their patients from state to state um we
heard in testimony only Missouri and
South Dakota have enacted legislation so
far so they would not be able to follow
from state to state unless another state
compact another reason for this
is the compact has not yet formed and
until the compact forms and puts its
rules in
place I think it's not appropriate for
the Hampshire to jump into that compact
not knowing what the rules
are when the compact is formed and the
rules are in place then we can look at
it we can go forward but I don't think
it's fair for everyone to come here
saying we should jump into a compact as
the state of New Hampshire not knowing
those
rules so for that reason and until it's
formed I I I cannot support this and for
one other reason and which is
unfortunate in this boilerplate language
one of my big sticking points Still
Remains just like in all the other
compacts I voted against is the ability
to lease purchase retain own hold
improve or use any property real
personal or mixed sell convey mortgage
pledge lease exchange abandoned
otherwise dispose of property or
personal mixed um for those Reasons I'm
I mean in a compact until that
boilerplate language is removed I mean
we're signing up for something we don't
even know what kind of property we're
talking about purchasing thank you okay
and represent
BR so as you can see there's a lot of
mixed
feelings on this issue but I'll be
voting against the itl because joing the
compact allows New Hampshire to be part
of that rul making process and to be
part of that and if it chooses at one
point not to belong to the compact it
can withdraw at any time so for me um
it's I'm I'm I'm going to be supporting
the I won't be supporting the itl but
I'm sure that it will be supported by
the committee and it is what it is and
people should vote their
right all
right man thank you Madam chair I also
want to bring to the attention compact
yes once it's
formed then it's not the core group
that's making the rule and setting the
compact up so if you want to be at the
table making or shaping this compact the
time is now I think and that's why I
cannot support the idea okay fair enough
reprentative Brown and then
Simon thank you madam chair I I I would
Echo uh what representative goalie said
to my right and follow up on
representative grod I think the
withdrawal has to be done
legislatively here at at the house and
it says 180 days after the enactment of
the repealing statute is how long it
takes to withdraw so I think that's kind
of a long time okay representative Simon
and then gold thank you madam chair uh
yes to representative mana's Point um I
understand the point that's being made
um however my concern would be just
being at the table to be able to set the
rules does not mean that we would get
the rules that we want we could have
input into them but we could be outvoted
by the other people who are in charge
and then we would be committed to the
compact at that point um without knowing
what those rules are going to be and
what they look like to representative
Goldie's point so I would I would still
have a bit of a concern
um with that even though we would be at
the table represent
gold clearly we have some division in
the committee on this one we can't all
agree on everything um having heard all
the testimony and having gotten so many
um Communications from social workers
supporting this knowing the crisis we
have in our state and knowing that 180
days to withdraw isn't the end of the
world and um a compact is not likely to
do anything that would be harming to the
public in those 180 days and knowing
that the office of professional licenser
supports this I it just is a no-brainer
for me I'll be not voting
itl anyone
else all right the motion is in me to
legislate on House Bill 1190 and the
clerk can call the role representative
Simon yes representative lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
santon oaso yes representative Dolan yes
representative gearhard yes cler vot yes
representative voyd yes representative
Brown yes Representative groa no
representative Schmidt no representative
goalie yes representative sht
yes Representative selig
no representative Davis
no representative Lane no representative
gold
no representative Smith no
yes
12a um 8 and
a all right motion passes 12 to8 I don't
consent so does someone wish to write a
Minority Report gladly all right
Report
note all right um on House Bill 1486
representative groa
yes I reluctantly move a itl on House
Bill
1486 is there a
second second second representative G
was
first all right do to speak to your
motion yes the subcommittee met and we
did have an amendment that would have
changed the bill from a requirement to a
data Gathering um position within um da
within the the
department
and when we spoke to Mr Arling house he
didn't have a method to do that but he
was certainly willing to discuss
it and after the emails that we received
recently which obviously seemed to
misunderstand the whole purpose of what
we were trying to do at this this point
I think it's better if we just and I've
spoken to the sponsor of the bill if we
just um itl the bill and try a different
way at a different
time thank you representative gold no
more to add to that representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair well I I
think one of the things is eminently
clear with regard of the current
situation is uh that this committee does
not understand this bill of the this
concept well enough uh to uh to make a
contribution other than saying this
doesn't seem to work so we're going to
it out I'm not saying that's an
irresponsible thing to do but I I think
that the reality is that carbon pricing
is coming to the world and and it's and
it's and it's coming here as well it
would be better to do it at the national
level clearly uh but we we I think the
correct uh better motion would be
interim study so that we can get to
understand the bill better thank
you repr lus thank you um I agree with
what's been said the the only thing I'd
add is that um I you know trying to use
the procurement process to achieve goals
uh you know from any perspective is
really not the best thing to do let's
leave the like the retirement system
let's leave the procurement process to
try and get the best deal for
the taxpayers of New Hampshire and if
there's something that needs to be done
uh in an area then that should be
handled as a separate matter uh not
enforced through procurement okay any
anyone else represent Simon uh thank you
madam chair I'll be supporting the itl
but representative Schmidt's Point um
I'll I will be voting itl understanding
the the proposal and the concept of the
bill uh but finding the methodology
faulty uh it it mixes economic structure
with social um with social sentiments um
and when the social sentiment is
basically the foundation of the model
it's not a purely economic system so I I
was unable to get anybody to explain to
me how we were going to come out with
any kind of accurate data or accurate
information um and it was kind of like
well some estimates better than nothing
um but I don't necessarily think that's
true I think if you make the estimate in
the wrong direction you're going to get
farther away from the truth and not
closer to the truth and uh you could end
up making very poor decisions that would
have real implications for the state um
so until we could come up with some sort
of system that could accurately measure
what the carbon cost would be I think it
would be irresponsible on our part to to
push a piece of legislation like this
else all right the motion is inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 1486 and the
clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santos Sasso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
geard yes clerk votes yes representative
Boyd yes representative Brown yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt no representative goalie
yes representative Shu yes
representative selig yes representative
Davis yes representative Lane yes
representative gold yes representative
Smith yes representative manuti yes and
the chair yes 19 y one nay okay motion
passes resident Schmid you object to
consent I'm okay with
consent okay does anyone else object to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
this on
consent all right right house bill 1271
representative leus you have a
motion yes I I do um it's ought to pass
with Amendment and let me
find the amendment
H would you repeat that number for those
of us with bad hearing uh
H and and it was handed out people
should have it uh it's it's a thick one
uh yeah it
is okay yeah we had some fun with this
one okay is there a second to
that okay that's leus and ghoul do you
wish to speak to your motion I do uh
first I'd like to thank everybody in the
subcommittee for doing an awful lot of
work on this thing
um
so make sure I
am getting
right okay so
this uh bill was uh to convert a number
of boards from uh regulatory to advisory
boards and to combine a couple of boards
and so first the
combination was uh comine combining the
r Advisory Board of massage therapists
with The Advisory Board of reflexology
structural integration agent body work
and that was at the request of those
boards um they they deal with some
similar issues and uh and so that was
what made sense um the rest of the
boards that were converted to advisory
boards were all boards that had um
relatively few um lenses and so there
were the usual concerns about a small
number you know Market participants uh
like you know regulating a small number
of lenses and and there were antitrust
and other concerns there uh we spent a
lot of our time on was going through and
closely examining the makeup of each one
of the the proposed boards because I
think when the bill was drafted it just
hacked them all down to three and that
didn't seem appropriate to us in all
cases so uh we took a close look at that
and then there were some general cleanup
U similar things that uh have been dealt
with in other bills um where there was
Authority left with the board and oplc
and some language changes uh in similar
areas but that's that's the core of what
H what we're doing and just one example
um is the uh the board of Midwifery
there's a total of 33 licensed midwives
in the state um and you know the three
that were on the
board uh you know made up almost 10% of
all the practicing midwives and that's
problematic but we did look at that one
and the you know the midwives were not
happy with the proposed makeup to the
board and we did expand it from three to
five and uh added back in three midwives
and two doctors in particular
Specialties they wanted so so we did
look at their
concerns
okay representative
gold um I would just add thank you madam
chair and thank you uh Tony leus
representative leus for all your work in
leading Us in the committee work uh I
know the Midwifery people were happy
with some of the gains in the amendment
I'll say so I think the committee worked
really hard to try to listen to the
concerns and
find the most common ground and and
touch a happy medium
note so that's about all I
said man thank you madam chair uh having
served on the
subcommittee um I still have concerns
about
um the transition of all the boards that
are listed from
um statutary board to
advisory and um I agree moving in that
direction but uh at still this time last
year the whole changes that have
happened that has not been implemented
to make more changes on top of it um I
am very skeptical about it so I do have
a hard time supporting the otpa
for I work I put in the hours with the
sub committee and uh my question always
lingered that so I still feel strongly
that you're not there
yet
okay having um spent my life in the last
two weeks with the amendment to
1095 I can tell you that the language in
this bill conflicts with what we have in
that um Amendment and
so we need to take a look at
um I'm not even sure if I have the brain
power right now to do it frankly so um I
think that we need to align these before
we accept it so maybe what we want to do
is
spend the next week doing that since
I'll be doing that with the amendment
1095 I just don't want to have more
problems I really I really appreciate
that because that makes a lot of sense
the other thing we could do is accept
this amendment and then
change 1095 which is already being
changed all over the place to to include
it but um or we
can we can choose to work on the two of
them together
yes representative G and then yes I
see thank you madam CH yes I know thank
you madam chair and uh to representative
groda um is is the difference the
inconsistencies you're talking about
regarding the authority to do things to
the executive director versus the
authority to do things to the
office well that's one and I and this is
the first time I've looked at this so I
just want to make sure that I don't miss
anything else but in all of the other
legislation that we've looked at we have
not used executive director we've used
um I just would like to have some I want
like some Harmony to this
because one of the issues that I'm that
I I didn't have before but I have now is
that when we touch something in oplc We
Touch 25 other things that we don't even
know we've
affected and it is
extremely difficult because then we end
up with 122 pages that we have to
literally go line by line word by word
now maybe that's
okay you know but when only one person
is doing it or two people are doing it
it's a heavy burden for that person on
top of everything else that they do and
I don't want to cause further GFF for
the committee I want us to you know have
a relationship that is I know I I know
among our peers I under we are on the
same page but to me our relationship
with oplc our relationship with the
office of legislative services our
ability to speak about this coherently
on the floor of the house are all
important
[Music]
okay representative
leus I I understand and really
sympathize with the concerns I mean I'll
leave how we deal with this up to the
chair but if the decision is to work
together on I'd be glad to do that I
thank you representative goalie I'm
sorry to was H over thank you madam
chair and I too agree with
as this same content is in two specific
bills we have before us and while it may
have been a chuckle from the attorney
oplc to talk about another 100 page Bill
coming forward I'm looking down the road
that the real possibility is there and
it's starting to get out of control they
need to start to work on areas that they
really want to change come forward with
bits in
pieces and not 100 page amendments on
changing big p pieces of the law that
are doing different sections at a time I
mean it it bothers me that we're here
doing this at this short of notice and I
know we worked
on trying through the process to get it
done in a timely manner but
in the way I look at it what we had
before us earlier today and I know we're
not there but this is part of that
should have been in front of us in
January to have a full two months to
review that and not two
weeks um
but I'll speak to the amendment in
itself and some of the reasons why I'm
it first is the first section and I'm
not sure why it's even in there the
purpose statement provide supervision
over regulatory bodies comprised of
active Market participants I don't know
needed second is we'll go down to line
18 on this explaining what oplc and the
director have the responsibilities to do
and the statement as the rules in effect
upon the effective date of this section
shall remain in effect until repealed by
the executive director I don't even know
why that needs to be in statute uh
because if you change the statute it
tends to invalidate the rule we don't
want to invalidate any
rules but unthinkingly that does need to
be there and you'll notice that's in in
different the different sections that is
important
yeah and I I still have the floor so
I'll continue
[Music]
on and as I've just seen this give me a
minute as I go through this looking at
forward
I ask her I'll stop for now and I'll uh
come back when I find the section I look
for thank you I appreciate your Thor
representative leus yeah I'll just uh
comment on the purpose part of it the uh
if you look at it um the purpose part
which is all through this uh you know
for each one of the
boards um there was certainly stuff in
there that I thought was unnecessary and
some people had an issue with and the
amendment does remove most of it maybe
there's more that could go out but but I
removed all that people who were
involved had an objection to so try to
accommodate that um
I'm anyone else
Simon uh thank you madam chair I I do I
am just curious um and I believe
representative Gera brought it up the
reference to the executive director I
know and looking at the other pieces we
we haven't used that language seems like
the only
place that we're using that language I
just don't know if that should be of
concern to the committee okay represent
laus yeah in the bill is originally
drafted it used that language in some
places and used office in the other
place and um if I recall correctly maybe
somebody else in the sub committee can
correct me but we we asked that of um
the executive director and attorney um
aoud and that's what they recommended um
and I didn't look I had a chance to look
at your 112 page
monstrosity um so that you got saddled
with so um it says office what it says
office and I went Page by Page line by
line with the executive director and Mr
O and no one said a peep yeah about
executive director which is a little
bit I'm yes I I don't want to get too
much but in U no in in
the but the reason we brought it up was
because because in some places in the
bill it did one thing and in some places
did the other and that's why the issue
came up for hours representative gold
yeah I just wanted to reinforce that um
a couple of things that have been said
here one is that uh my colleagues who
have recognized that we've done an
excruciating amount of work on some very
intricate um bills on licensing and and
so you know I just think some of this is
inevitable but specifically on this
topic um it came up I believe it was
representative maputi who pointed out
that she was really bothered by the
inconsistency and then the office
clarified that um well the office the
executive director and the attorney of
of
oplc um pointed out that it takes an
individual to take action that an office
really can't so that in a legal
technical sense it should be office it
should be the executive director
throughout and so I know we talked about
it um the inconsistency that we were
seeing with some of these other bills I
just think the bottom line is that I
support 100% let's take another week and
um and see what we can do to to iron out
some of the inconsistent language yeah
I'm I'm
sure rather disappointed to discover
that large portions of this SE this bill
are duplicative to sections that are in
the amendment to
1095 and I think that we ought to when
looking at it we ought to put the
sections in either one or the other but
please not both it makes things much
easier for everybody and so in light of
that I think we will recess this
executive
session uh thank you go look at the
language and make sure sure it is not
duplicative or conflicting with house
house bill
and we hope come up with clean
amendments on both of
them
yes so we're not up against the deadline
yet are we this bill must be voted out
of committee by the
21st we I'm recessing this until I
understand but I I think this is a very
wise DEC ision on your part Madam chair
the the thing is if we're not up against
the
deadline we can do I there's a lot of
work that's been done I haven't been
involved in most of it but let's do just
a little bit more and get it right it's
not quite as this is not commensurate
with the kind of work product this
committee ordinarily produces yet so
let's let's try and make it better and I
think it might make sense to take to
look at it and take some sections out of
one one bill and and put and and make
sure that we don't have duplicate
sections so um representative laus and
sessions all right we will recess that
simpler okay
all right on House Bill
1059 I move a to pass with
H I'll second that Amendment I'll second
okay it's
amendment
okay it's my okay
so as recommended by the
amendment
simply includes building code review
board amendments approved as of January
instead of November because they
included they had a few more minor ones
which were sent to the committee and
then made the effective date July
1st for Simplicity and that's the new um
new fiscal year just to give it a fixed
date for for convenience this was the
recommendation of the subcommittee and
representative
brodic I have nothing else Dad thank you
okay anyone else comments questions
representative Simon thank you madam
chair could you just remind me the
purpose of the striking out of 12
through
14 it's that's not a change in the
amendment it's not okay that's in the in
the bill itself it's in the original
bill right yes Y and it
um I think get covered
elsewhere
okay represent manager
ptin thank you madam chair my question I
don't know who can answer but uh I'm
confused as to there's another building
code bill I believe right with the clean
energy or this is the one that was the
energy portion of it energy conservation
code is part of
bill do references but does not update
the energy code this we had an amendment
that we discussed at the hearing and we
discussed in subcomittee and decided not
to
accept do you wish to know
why no so I that that clarifies my
question as to this that clean the
energy portion is not part of it so the
energy portion is not included okay
because we were convinced that it had
too many unintended
consequences and it had
also um increase the cost for homes in
particular much more than it then would
it can I follow up ask you another
question um the energy for commercial
meaning anything over four units for
residential would be considered
commercial
correct uh not exact residential is no
more than three
it's in some size limit which I I forget
and so a
small business business could be covered
under the residential code um what more
than four
stories
is is commercial by definition and over
I forget how many thousand feet 5,000 I
think is is commercial we can we asked
about incorporating the commercial
energy code but
we we are not skilled enough to do that
our ourselves and the people that are
skilled enough couldn't come to an
agreement on how to do that
to better not to to try and split it
than to do it really badly which is how
I guess the subcommittee would do it one
last
one uh so my concern with that is that
with so many housing crisis multi 150
unit uh complexes Workforce
uh you name it market rate Workforce low
income housing all those things coming
up not having a clear understanding of
where this you know where we stand with
the Energy Efficiency and conservation
coming up from ground app would be a
detriment because retrofitting the these
buildings would be more costly than
coming up and on the same token with
um keep you know passing this we have an
option to see if there's a way to do
something at the floor
or right amend it at the uh in the floor
thanks anyone else representative
Shuan thank you madam chair um both in
the Committee hearing and in the
subcommittee hearing
particularly uh we heard a lot of pro
and con uh regarding the energy portion
uh the fact of the matter is that I
think the mood of this committee is that
we do need to adopt uh updating the
building codes for right now and that's
where this amendment with this bill will
take us um if we feel that we need to
update the energy portion uh we will
you anyone else representative Brown um
thank you m chair I want to speak to the
energy portion but in the L in the
discussion going ahead shall I wait
oh it's not relevant to the amendment
specifically that's okay it's that'll
simplify the discussion of the of the
ought to pass
motion okay
um so obviously we've all received a lot
of information I think it's it would be
my suggestion for everyone in the
committee to look at one of the emails
that sent us um the 2021 iecc and the
energy appendix for
that uh no one discussed this when they
proposed the the iecc going to
2021 in the energy appendix and i' I've
looked at this and I've done a little
other reading so it's my
interpretation it says
specifically that this appendix will
allow jurisdictions towns Andor
cities to require Residential Building
to mean Net Zero Energy meaning you have
to produce as much energy as you use in
your house and your jurisdiction can do
that within the time frame that they
choose so if we were to pass the 2021
ICC no one mentioned this appendix which
can put a a pretty serious cost on
residential housing in separate
communities if I'm reading it
correctly thank you thank you other
comments president V py sorry madam all
right chair um yes Net Zero is that are
couple of definition of Net Zero um in
terms of trying to see the it's not the
energy produced it's the passive Energy
Efficiency conservation and uh usage to
reduce the carbon footprint and that
also qualifies as Net Zero and I think
by
adopting um
2021 building code that will give us the
opportunity to see how that can be done
in the new constructions especially the
Mega um buildings or uh all the new
upcoming one to be done so if the
building code is already if this is
adopted it will help
with bring you know bringing that energy
and
climate code
into being if this passes it will enable
that I think that's my understanding I
could be totally wrong
but that's my
understanding uh thank you madam chair
as someone that works on job sites and
builds houses daily well except for
Saturday and Sunday mostly um I think a
lot of these building codes are just
excessive and unnecessary we talk about
lowering the cost of housing but I mean
I'm on a job right now up in molten Boro
on Squam one of those multi-million
dollar houses but the
excessive
um the extent that they make you go to
to secure just a three-story Tower with
these concrete foundations it's it's
really absurd and if you really want to
get an idea of what's going on you
should go to these job sites and talk to
these high school dropouts that are
working on these job sites and building
houses they know much more than we do
and as far as the energy conservation
stuff goes a house okay just real quick
up in Sandwich working on on a barn this
seill plate need to be replaced this
thing has been standing since the late
1700s the we're making these houses
airtight right now which is not helping
anything they're rotting from the inside
out and the plywood if you look at it's
all stamped exempt from from Al from
alahh
regulations so um anyway point being is
we're making these toxic boxes that are
airtight that if you look at when you
put in doors in Windows it actually
tells you that the houses have negative
pressure now it's actually sucking in
water from the outside side so anyway
people need to breathe houses need to
breathe and I think a lot of these
energy conservation things they might
mean well but I don't think they
actually have common sense put into play
so that's all I'm going to say I think
you should talk to people building
houses stop over one time when you see
somebody and just talk to them I think
you might learn a few things so thank
you madam chair I just have to you know
I am in that Consulting business of
building Net Zero commun communities and
buildings and uh that whole efficiency
energy and I'm not talking from just
theoretical knowledge so I do understand
the codes and the glean and passive
buildings that are coming up and New
Hampshire is way behind it but
that's that's not my point it is it's
happening whether we like it or not
Across the Nation across the globe and
so the more we adopt and look at it
preemptively it's not this whole um
monstrosity of Energy Efficiency and
climate change is a cost to the rate
payers is really
not based in reality so that's my two
cents so I just want to make sure that
um I'm not speaking from just Theory and
uh things so I just wanted to bring that
to attention thank you madam chair and
I'm sure that that from that you are
well aware that the owner of the project
can requ
request
um require and request settings that are
vastly exceeding what the building code
requires and I I that's what point that
I want to make the building code should
be the minimum necessary for safe
buildings and the builders
are and the owners are entitled to make
to add additional requirements all they
want and many of them
do representative round uh thank you
madam chair for letting me fog this a
little bit
more
um to your point building code should be
for safety for to make sure our
buildings are constructed properly for
people's safety if you read this
appendix here's what it says about the
iecc about 300 cities and counties and
10 states are signatories to the we are
still in commitment supporting climate
action to meet the goals of the Paris
climate
Accord and over 150 cities have
committed to using 100% renewable energy
more are joining all the time the
building energy code is an important
policy tool for jurisdictions as they
pursue these types of goals that is not
about safety that's about climate
change thank you representative Brown
any other
comments
okay not seeing any the motion is to
adopt
Amendment
0804 and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
leakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative santon Sasso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
geard yes clerot yes representative Boyd
yes representative Brown yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes representative
selig yes representative D Davis yes
representative Lane yes representative G
yes representative
Smith yes representative manap py yes
and the chair yes 20 a09 all right and
I'll move ought to pass with Amendment
BR all right does anyone else have
add yes 4% of gold just quickly I'll say
I will support the itl on this but I
will look forward to if an amendment
comes forward on the floor to add the
energy code back in because I would say
that a destroyed planet is not very safe
for people to live on thank you thank
you for that any other
comments representative Dolan
oh yes I know she made a mistake she
meant she's not voting yes on otpa okay
that's what she meant all right all
right I figured that thank you for that
clarification because I thought I knew
what we were doing until I
heard that's okay all right so we shall
all hang together anyone else we shall
all hang together indeed so the motion
is ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 1059 and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakus yes representative
Bailey yes representative santon naso
yes representative Dolan yes
representative geard yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes I think
representative goalie yes representative
sht yes representative seling yes
representative Davis yes representative
Lane yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
maputi yes and the chair yes 20 a0
n okay motion passes 20 to Zer does
anyone object to
consent representative manip objects to
right moving right
along
one uh representative goalie do you have
16006 sure uh I move in expedient to
legislate is there a second
I'll second okay representa goalie you
wish to speak to your
motion yes um I think during the
testimony uh we heard from uh director
goule that this is already being done
and in the process of being done on as
many uh web pages as they can going
forward um so I I feel that this is not
necessary I think it's been um made loud
and clear that this should be a prior
and I think he understands that and with
that I'll leave it at that represent gr
do you to speak to your second yes thank
you um during the testimony we do hear
the department of information
Technologies is working on a um
consistent design for web pages for the
state agencies that includes that
information and therefore it's already
idea okay anyone else representative
Smith
thank you madam chair well I think there
is some argument for some
individuality I think to the degree that
our web pages have a
certain uniform look so that the that
public who doesn't deal with this every
day when they when they go from one page
to another at least have some idea you
know which side of the road they're
they're going to be driving on so to
speak so I think that this is
probably uh the way we ought to go thank
you anyone else yeah i' have to agree
that this is the way we ought to go and
uh I plan to start checking a few
websites after they've had a chance to
put them new ones up and make sure that
the contact and button is right up
there but uh I think I think they got
the
point representative Brown I I would as
the sponsor as you all know I'd say
thank you for for your consideration I
agree and um at least it got them off
dead center and moving what I think we
think is in the right direction so thank
you all okay anyone
else okay the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
16006 and the clerk can call the rooll
representative Simon yes representative
lakus yes representative Bailey yes
representative sanos Sasso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
G
absent oh he stepped out
okay repres um yeah clerk vess
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative selig yes
representative Davis yes representative
Lane yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
manager py yes in the chair yes 19 y0 N
okay any objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
this one on consent and since we are
moving right along I I'm suggesting a
10-minute break so we can stretch our
legs
yeah
not
here guess we'll have to do a different
one what's that 1411 yeah I was going I
was going to do 1408 but Cherry's not
here all right uh resuming our executive
session House Bill 1411 representative
groda yes um on House Bill 1411 Madam
chair I move
itl is there a
second I'll second
it do you wish to speak to your motion
yes thank you you might recall that this
bill was um was written was submitted to
us because um there was a constituent
who had difficulty in paying with cash
at um State agencies especially the
turnpike and upon speaking to
um Mr Arling house commissioner Arling
house and um it seems that All State
agencies take cash except for the toll
boots on sping turpike and it's highly
unlikely that we're going
to um pay someone to um collect cash
there but there are
non-traceable
um easy passes that you can get that
would allow individuals to um use that
so I didn't we didn't it wasn't I didn't
think this bill was
necessary I'd like to say that I spent
some time talking with someone from the
Department of Transportation about those
toll boots and there are at least three
different ways you can set up a cash
program the simplest is that you will
not is just go through the tolls without
paying and once a week go in and pay
your previous week's tolls because you
won't get charged a a fee until it's at
least eight days so you can and they do
take cash at the uh at the service
stations and there's
one near the tolls in I think it's
do uh you could also get a trans
transponder an Easy Pass transponder and
set it up with cash that will not you
can either get an anonymously or in your
name and that will save you 30% on the
tolls which will pay for the cost of the
transponder in about two weeks if you're
going through once a day so and there
are other things you can do
but it's a little more difficult if all
you have is Cash you but but it is
it can be managed without extra fees and
I think that considering the cost of
having somebody out there
taking of collecting the tolls it's not
worth reinstituting toll collectors to
aggravation because everybody else is
going to be paying for the uh the toll
collectors representative cik thank you
so much I I just want to say as someone
who regularly drives the spaling
turnpike and uh now gets to drive them
much more efficiently because there
aren't the cash Lanes of the two lanes
that we have um it's also become much
safer because we're not having traffic
that is driving unfortunately at
excessive speed suddenly breaking from
uh by 50 to 60 miles per hour in a
matter of seconds and not necessarily
efficiently so um streamlining that
process in my opinion is is best
and you y thank you madam chair um so
I'm in support of this and although I I
would like to follow up on
representative gr's comments after I'm
done
um many of us probably in in the house
have not experienced or maybe even had
exposure to a person who could only pay
their bills by
cash sometimes it happens people are in
a bad place they have a bad credit
rating they have in fact as as I was
have explained to others sometimes you
find out that people don't have a bank
account and they can't get one because
they've had such a difficult time with
money they can't get a they can't get a
bank account they can't have a debit
card there and a lot of these
people work on a Cash basis they'll go
to Walmart and cash their paycheck so
they have cash in their hand and then
maybe they have to do money orders at
Walmart to pay their bills they don't
have a checkbook they don't have any way
to do that I think
that it's important for us to consider
that and say that everyone should have a
a chance to pay their bill as necessary
and as I said from from
16006 We're the state we aren't a
commercial entity commercial entities
are trying to do everything they can can
to make money to not have you call them
on the phone or not have you pay cash
and to do everything online that's not
who we are at the state we're public
servants we're supposed to be providing
service to the people that need it so I
think that allowing a person to have
cash payments I think is necessary that
being said um the sponsor as we saw at
the hearing the sponsor had never
thought about the toll booths that's
something until I came up in in a
question that that she hadn't thought
about and obviously we can't uh uh
restaff toll booths for the few people
that can't pay cash and that that would
have that's an outlier on this although
there are some solutions so that's kind
of how I feel on it but I'd like to
follow up with representative Grody you
talked to
um thank you and can can you maybe
elaborate a little bit more on what that
he said about he checked all the state
agencies that deal with the public and
they all have the ability to take cash
so and I hope that
my expedient way of explaining that did
not indicate my any callousness towards
anyone who would be in any financial
position that would only allow them and
that's their prerogative I mean they
could be some people only deal in cash
okay so um I just feel that since it's
available we should it's not something
that we need to direct agencies to
do may may Madam shair follow up and
then representative Schmidt yeah thank
you Representative groa no I didn't
think that in the leaste that's not not
at all thank you representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair well I
recall like 50 years ago when I was
working in Chicago in a patent law
office and we had uh everyone of the
patent
attorneys had a a girl that's the way
they called him in those days they were
overwhelming the women uh and and most
of them uh were very fine people see all
seem to be well very well educated they
all belong to a particular uh uh
European ethnic group and every every
payday they took their their ship their
paycheck and went downstairs to the bank
this was in the SE 70th floor of the
Sears Tower Bank was in the on the first
floor they went down and cash our
paycheck uh and so forth and I was kind
of as stunned at the idea that people
who were in the patent law business and
on one on one end were had people who
were cashing their checks I'm going like
all that money all that wasted so forth
and so on but now
50 years later uh the the bottom line is
we don't we don't even think about it
because we've all got a transponder
right or if we want one anyway because
we're in the house um and the balding
now is clean and green you just get on a
one end and you never stop again until
your car runs out of gas if you've got a
car that still burns gas so the bottom
line is but the the this was a little
humorous interlude I hope but that we
are also state representatives that have
constituencies and many of us are in
small towns or we're pretty close to the
the the center of government in our town
so I suggest that we talk with them
about how they deal with that situation
because the state doesn't want to put
toll collectors back on the toll toll uh
highways that's not going to happen
but we have to be mindful of the fact
that there are people a lot of people
out there that we probably don't even
think about it that are still paying
cash for everything and and and we have
to I so let's talk with our local
um with our local government and see how
they deal with it because it could be
that we have to make some additional
adjustments at the state level because
we can't push down on the
28a says we can't push things down on
the towns but let's find out how our
towns how our constituents are dealing
with people who will only pay cash
because we need to know that and this
bill bangs Us in the head with a larger
2x4 representative gold thank you madam
chair and um to representative Schmidt's
point at the full Committee hearing I
think I reported that I had uh gotten a
parking ticket and didn't want my
husband to know and tried to go into the
conquered Police Department to pay cash
and they refused to accept it I'm happy
to report that very day that I reported
that in this committee meeting I went
out and I had a parking ticket and when
my husband got online to pay it he saw
that you can pay cash at the conquered
police department so I do think we're
seeing a a return to municipalities
accepting cash payments and I just
wanted to reassure you but I like your
point we should all check in our own
municip
if I may I mean the thing is that it it
locality want but that if let's ask them
how they handle it and then if if the
people can come in and pay their their
state
Bill State charge at their
locality the the towns are all dealing
with the state so let's just find out
more I'm sure we can
profit from more
information representative Shu thank you
madam chair um as someone whose late
brother-in-law was exactly the person
that representative Brown was
describing could not keep a bank account
cashed his Social Security checks at
Walmart um but even he with his
disabilities
learned about a place where he could get
money orders
I think they allowed three a
month uh he and my sister paid most of
their utility bills in cash but the
instances where he could not use cash he
would get a money order and send it to
or take it to whatever Place needed to
be paid so there are ways that folks
that have these problems can deal with
things uh it may be a matter of
education but
I just wanted to point that out thank
you repr
Gart thank you madam
chair what happened to having the toll
booths take coins and then the little
gate opens up and there is no person
necessary that's the first thing and the
second thing with this is I think the
bigger issue is an uh anonymity and the
fact that people don't always want the
government at all levels especially the
higher up level want knowing what you're
doing with your money so I think just
the idea that if cash is legal tender
then it should be accepted everywhere so
thank you yes and I will I will report
that when I was at the Secretary of
State's
office earlier this week filing
a a business uh application the person
at the next window was taking $50 bills
out of his wallet to pay for for his uh
similar license so they do take cash and
checks which is why I was there because
I didn't didn't have a credit card for
the
business so yeah the tolls are a
specific case and but there are ways
around it representative Bailey I'm I'm
inclined to this had problems to friend
example but I would point out that what
it says on all your bills you can look
in your wallet is this is legal tender
for all debts public and private the
cash money I believe it's already
illegal to not accept paper
tender well there are there are places
out there that will not take anything
over
20 representative Mani thank you madam
chair just going back to the easy path
there is a path where you can get prea
transponder that you pay money ahead of
time and when you run out you run out so
you can go refill it and that is an one
of the options and I had one of the
constituents who did not want to pay
they got that and what you talked about
Madame chair they were out of country or
whatever for two weeks so they had to
pay penalty they went through the toll
they got the uh thing but if they had
gone back and paid it within the week
there won't be any penalty and it'll be
mailed and your car is reg registered
anyways so you can't hide the fact that
where the registration is addressed to
so that is if you don't want to go
through toll then you don't have to but
your registered car will go through that
so there are options and you know it's
just a matter of finding those options
to work thank
you all right anyone else all right
we've all told our cash cash stories and
uh the motion is inexpedient to
legislate the uh clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo naso yes
representative Dolan yes Representative
gearhard no clerk votes no
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown no representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
sht yes representative selig yes
representative Davis yes representative
Lane yes representative gold given that
so many are accepting cash yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 1783
consent Madam chair it is FN it still
can go it's not a large FN
not you don't have to speak to it all
right we'll put this on the regular
calendar since there appears to be some
concern does anyone write want to write
a Minority Report I I will do that okay
and represent Brown will write The
Minority Report not a bad idea for the
rest of the house to at least
momentarily think about this we heard
these stories but and thought about it
okay Ross that's
one representative Bailey you have a
motion on House Bill 12
1272 yes I'd like to move itl on House
Bill 1272
FM uh I'll
second okay do you wish to speak to your
motion I understand there's a potential
conflict or problem could be created uh
in that
this uses the term remarkably Sim uh
reasonably similar which has the
potential to conflict with existing
things that a scope of practice that
have Divine particular scopes of
practice and this would allow in things
that are not that must be called similar
because they have the same
name and perhaps are not
similar okay representing
okay I'd like to say that we passed a
very broad
reciprocity Bill last year and it is
still being implemented in rules and I I
think it's wise not to change the ground
rules until we finished establishing the
basis for reciprocity
I anyone
else all right seeing seeing PS
representative gold having worked on the
committee thank you madam chair for
those remarks I agree I think that was
yeah anyone else all right the motion is
in expedient to legislate on House Bill
1272 and the clerk can call the role
represent Simon yes representative
leakas yes representative Bailey yes
Representative santon no Sasso yes
representative Dolan yes Representative
geard
no clerk votes yes representative voyd
yes representative Brown yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu sorry representative
salig yes representative Davis yes
representative Lane yes representative
Gould yes representative Smith yes
representative manab booody yes and the
enough that that means you're not
writing a Minority Report even okay
good house bill 1408 representative
motion term study as far as
I uh Madam chair I
move interim study for House Bill
1408 okay is there a second second by
representative leus do you wish to speak
to your
motion I will Madam
chair the committee heard many concerns
about the board mergers and many changes
made last year uh with the office of
Professional Licensing some of the rules
from last year's changes are just now
getting final ANZ the subcommittee
worked on many changes for an amendment
we agreed in the end that it's not quite
ready but given a little time and a bit
more work it could address areas that
need to be cleaned up for moving
ahead representa laus thank you I agree
with that and in addition um we had some
concerns that there might have been
stuff in here that would impinge on
representative grod's uh Amendment she's
working on which is one of the reasons
we did interim study rather than itl
because we didn't want to do something
that would stand in the way of
polite is very decent yes represent
manager py thank you madam echo my
colleagues on the subcommittee and that
was a major conversation in terms of not
impeding uh 162
page amendment that representative gr
yeah all right anyone else
comment okay in that case the motion is
interim study on House Bill 1408 and the
clerk can call the role represent Simon
yes represent Lakers yes representative
Bailey yes representative santon staso
yes representative Dolan yes
representative gearhard yes clerk vote
Yes representative Boyd yes
representative
Brown yes representative GR
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
sht yes representative oops I'm
sorry sorry salig
yes representative Davis
yes representative Lane yes
representative gold yes representative
Smith yes representative man py yes and
the chair yes 20 z a
okay motion passes 20 any objections to
consent all right seeing none we'll go
for
consent and last one house bill 1222
representative
gold yes Madam chair I would like to
okay I think do we have an amendment for
this one right I believe so I'd like to
move a to pass on the amendment
number
okay
it's it's by Roos Fort and Edwards not
by somebody on the
committee okay representative goul do
you wish to speak to your
motion uh yes Madam chair I think we're
gonna have a different motion after this
then ought to pass as amended but I
think that um voting for the amendment
to the original bill is still a good
move as as this continues on in its
process
okay representative leus on the
amendment
um thank you this
amendment makes some changes around
there there were I guess requested by
the Veterans Administration people uh
around the language of that part of the
bill
and I
remember and it makes some um
you know it says it takes the language
that had said to an appropriate position
or other health care professional to
appropriate member of the health care
team um part of the issue is is that you
know the the person that would be
appropriate to talk with might or to
consult with might not actually be a
physician uh you could have AR NPS and
others who might um be the person
running it
so
okay any other comments questions
concerns on the
amendment Manti are you no I'll wait for
after the amendment
okay I do have some concerns about so if
amendment all right let's let's just get
the amendment done that's that's the
best way to do it I'm
sorry no other questions on the
amendment all right in that case the
motion is to adopt amendment
0454 to House Bill 1222 and the clerk
can call the role representative Simon
yes representative lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Santo naso yes representative Dolan yes
representative gearhard yes clerk votes
yes representative Boyd yes
representative
Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative
goalie yes representative Shu yes
representative selig yes representative
Davis yes representative Lane yes
representative gold yes representative
Smith yes representative
manuti yes and the chair yes 20
a0 all right we have adopted the
amendment a Rec representative gold
uh Madam I'd like to Madam chair I'd
like to move interim study for House
Bill 122 as with
amendment is there a
second
okay wait a minute do we want to do inum
study or do we wna recess this until the
next
hearing difference
I just need a little bit of um technical
advice on how an inim study can we take
it back up next week if we no no okay
interim study is final disposition for
the bill it says that we don't we won
don't want to pass it this year but we
will continue to work on it okay thank
you madam chair uh then I would like to
resend that motion all right because as
I understand it what we want to do is
work on this um for uh so a resolution
for next week a hearing next week can I
EXA yes representative BR do you have a
this there's no motion we have not had a
motion there's no motion point of order
then if there's no motion then there's
no discussion because there's no motion
ah we have adopted the amendment I'll
make an otpa motion if that would move
things along okay representative leus
moves all to pass with Amendment and
representative second it and we now we
can discuss it all right thank you for
that point of V okay representative gr
thank you we're on the basic bill as
amended right so my con
my this bill I'm I'm sure everyone's not
going to be surprised to hear it's not
it's not one of my favorite
bills um there have been certain things
along this has been this has had a very
bumpy road
first of all um there was no
collaboration from the physic from the
Pas with anybody from the Board of
Nursing or anyone from the Board of
Medicine and these are people that
they're supposed to collaborate with and
there was no discussion with them about
this bill number one number two there
was no discussion about how the scope of
practice was going to change because
within the collab within the scope of
practice collaboration between the
Physicians plays a very important part
these individuals are called physician
assistants and there's a reason for
that number two three we were told that
other states have adopted this and Maine
was one of them and indeed Maine did
adopt a bill but it is not this bill
it's quite different than this bill and
this morning we heard that the Board of
Medicine has indeed agreed with the Pas
on an on a on a relationship and they
are willing to put an amendment together
which I'm willing to look at but we
don't have
um it is not this is this is something
that started out as I was told and I
think that we heard this too that the
bill wasn't going to be submitted then
it was submitted then it was well you
know the Pas are talking about it but
nobody else knows about it this is not
the way to decide IDE how legislation is
made you don't do it this way it's kind
of halfhazard this is an important thing
we're talking about People's Health Care
and it's not something that we can just
say flip a switch and go okay let's do
it this way and then decide that that's
not the way anybody else is doing it so
let's do it this way there's just too
many moving parts to this so I I I
understand the need and the recognition
that we want to do something but I would
like to um take and I appreciate
representative ghoul trying to make an
effort to
um speak to the
bill but I'd like to see what other
states are doing because in many of
these in in these bills for example the
state of Maine has adopted a legislation
that does not allow newly graduated
students for their physical physician
assistance to practice on their own and
they need a certain amount of hours
before they can practice on their own
and I'm I'm willing to take a look at
that and I hope that the committee will
agree with me that this is something
that we should
consider and I've said my piece thank
you all right that's very interesting
represent leus and the
meny thank you um yeah I understand the
concerns of the process I I wasn't
involved in all the history
um I mean I would be fine passing this
ought to pass as amended I mean I can
mention some reasons for that but if
it's you know if there's some process
for and also from the uh I think Mr kzy
I don't know if he's here uh he I we
spoke with him earlier and he said the
Board of Medicine would be neutral on
the bill as it stands but they would
prefer an amendment that required
certain things
first um and I don't know what the
procedure would be to somehow address
that but I you know if that's where the
committee want the procedure to address
it would be to add add language to the
bill make an
amendment
um or pass it as is and hope hope it's
fixed in the
Senate which I do personally do not
recommend if I can ask I mean if to add
language what would we do today then get
an amendment but oh but we don't have an
amendment with drawing
motion or we just we just recess it and
and come in with another
amendment
um representative Mani thank you madam
chair um I did um Express this concern
looked at it uh from the nurse
practitioners versus PA and Pa's
physician assistants are still under
Medical board and me Physicians are the
ones that are setting the scope and
supervision and to get them to expand uh
the medical uh care provide you know
care providers increasing the numbers so
that there is quality safety in our
state in terms of providing it by
suddenly now that you know it's not a
small tether that's still hanging but to
give the PE that don't have the same um
I I shouldn't say not have the same but
the education training and the scope of
uh
services are very well defined under
Medical Board and suddenly we are not
going to be part of that but we are
going to be independent they don't have
an independent board so we are really
putting our Granite Staters safe safety
basic
medical
um Health Care at risk by not having
that consistency so I mean I couldn't
support this we hashed a lot of uh
details at the subcommittee and that was
you know and I spent few few days the
week of uh break
uh you know to figure out what you know
how is it so it is still not there so I
couldn't support it's up to pass all
right thank you representative leus and
then gold and then Brown okay um yeah I
don't share those concerns on the health
health stuff although I understand them
um I mean it looks like there's two
options one is to try and and push
through in the vote the motion we have
on the floor um uh the other one would
be I can withraw the motion and we can
consider the amendment I and I I'm
leaning towards the latter um I have a I
have a number of concerns with this one
is you know we heard testimony that
um Pas are having first of all that they
do have and there somebody else can
probably speak more to it but you know
while it's a different training path
they have similar amounts of training
and clinical as uh arnps as
NPS um the other
um testimony were heard was that
Southern New Hampshire Family Practice
ended up getting rid of all their Pas
and replacing with arnps and we actually
you my wife and I deal with them and we
wonder why there were no Pas and that
was because they had trouble getting
doctors to do collaboration agreements
but since arnps didn't need them they
replaced them with those um and that's I
think a serious problem
so uh you know my preference would be to
pass the Bill W with this amendment that
we adopted
um for a number of reasons and my and I
know there's a proposal to add some
number of hours under collaboration if
we even have it go away my concern with
that is that's that's not going to solve
that problem if they're having trouble
getting a collaboration agreement um
yeah no that other people right and U
people lined up I mean I'll I'll listen
some more but at least I'm thinking
about where to go on this representative
Simon thank you madam chair um and I I
understand uh some of the frustration on
the committee I just wanted to clarify
one thing that I believe I remember
correctly um from the testimony uh just
on behalf of the Pas um they weren't the
ones to originally bring the legislation
um a couple Representatives did when
they found out that the legislation was
brought forward um a originally they
didn't know what to do with it but then
they're like no we really do want this
so then they started to support it I
believe they supported it in
subcommittee um and then um the medical
association showed up to testify and I
did ask the question there are four
states that do do this and I don't
believe Maine was one of those States um
but uh I asked if there had been any
negative Health outcomes from doing that
in those other states we never heard
back from them so I'm assuming that
means that there weren't anything uh
there wasn't anything of major concern
because they did show up for the
subcommittee meetings um but didn't
testify to that I just feel like as the
process has gone on more and more people
have just kind of come on board with it
uh if the Board of Medicine is neutral
on this they've looked at it they've
considered it and they're now neutral on
it as it stands they'd be in support of
it um directly if we brought in this
other Amendment but they're neutral on
it now which means to me that they don't
see any major concern of actual harm
being done if we were to pass it this
way um and I just feel like when you
look at the requirements between nurse
practitioners and physicians assistant
which yes has the name assistant in it
um but that may just have to do with the
way that it developed over time more
than how you know the the requirements
now I'm sure that the requirements that
they had to go through when it first
came out aren't the same as they are now
I'm sure we've increased those
requirements over time um if nurse
practitioners are allowed to practice
independently straight out of school and
Physicians assistants have to put in
more hours than nurse practitioners do
um before they can get their degree it
just seems to me that we're not treating
everybody equally these people are just
as um qualified to to practice the
medicine and their um particular realm
of practice and I just don't think it's
fair and and since at this point I don't
know of anybody in the medical industry
that is outright opposed to the bill as
it stands with this amendment that we
just passed um I don't see any reason
why we would keep Physicians assistance
from being able to practice
independently in the
state representative Gould thank you
madam chair so I apologize for my what
appeared to be waffling we did a great
deal of Outreach and research and I
think representative leus who chaired
the subcommittee has represented it well
but I'll just reinforce that it was very
clearly laid out to us by the physicians
assistant that their training differs
slightly from uh nurse practitioners but
at the end of seven years of training
they are equivalent positions my
daughter who's a nurse practitioner and
who testifies before Congress and writes
whatever she's way up there she clearly
um stated uh if you talk to her or other
nurse practitioners or the nursing board
you'll probably hear how their training
is superior to the physician assistant
training but at the end of seven years
they're equivalent and so bottom line is
of course each profession feels theirs
is the best but they both agree that at
the end of 7 years they are equivalent
and for the very reasons representative
Simon has spoken I've felt very strongly
that we shouldn't have a schizophrenic
scenario in New Hampshire where we're
allowing nurse practitioners to do what
we don't allow their exact equivalent on
the physician training side The
Physician assistance to
do however understanding that there was
some reluctance I was willing to listen
to or give a week's time to looking at
um the possibility that we would need an
amendment to get more support but after
hearing all this testimony especially
that the uh Physicians board you know
the concerns regarding the Physicians
board doesn't already have uh procedure
set up I did get clarification that as
we've talked about with all these
different bills the changes that were
done last year did not affect the
Medical Board in the same way that it
affected all the other boards so they're
in a much better position to be able to
have the time to write the scope of
practice if they're saying they would
support this bill as a it's written I
think it's kind of a no-brainer we
should support it they neutral neutral
but they would not oppose it not oppos
thank you is a step okay represent
Schmidt did you were
you so I I I'm fundamentally okay with
the idea of the physician's assistance
uh losing that tether that is holding
them back in some respects uh with
regard to not what they can do but how
they can do it uh and it was emphasized
and I sat in on the subcommittee and
emphasized that basically both both both
entities are
doing Medical Care effectively and so
forth and so on it's just the physicians
assistant have to have somebody their
tether to that signs off in a way but
they the testimony was that they in many
cases they don't have contact with that
person they are not being supervised by
that person uh and so forth so I'm
sympathetic to the
PA's you know cause here but it seems
like there's a little bit of factual
uncertainty about some aspects of this
that would that would benefit since we
have an executive session scheduled for
next week and we can move this over to
that point that that we at least
consider investigating some of this
unclarity so that we operating all on
the same page that's
all represent
Goldie thank you madam chair and in
difference to my colleague I I do want
to say there are not exactly the same
nurse practitioner or physician
assistants they're not equival they're
not exactly equivalent that is a not
correct statement I just want to go on
record stating that that there are two
different practices a physician
assistants ner prer are not exactly
equal and I will state that I will not
support this um listening to this
discussion around the table that this
bill could be made better with an
amendment I think
we owe that for this committee to if we
can make a bill better to do
that I think we all take pride in the
work we do
here and I would hope going forward we
could do that I mean we've done it with
a previous Bill we're working on 112
pages that we said we can make
better this is a short piece of work and
if we're going to do it let's make it
better um okay representative continue
represent I I
was contacted by some individuals up in
Littleton who this would
affect
and and the the email that they sent
it's seemed like the intent was so that
they could have their private practice
without having the
physician and if that was the reason
this bill was put in and then all of a
sudden got the train rolling for
everybody else to jump on board you know
I'm not sure that's the reason we should
this there's a lot of other aspects to
this we need to look at the surrounding
states are we've heard from
representative groa about Maine and the
testimony that well Maine has done it
well they
haven't
so let's get the facts straight before
we pass
something thank you represent Brown did
you have a comment uh thank you madam
chair um so I'll apologize to my
subcommittee members for apparently
having changed my mind uh up
front uh to to representative goalie's
comment uh the New Hampshire Society of
Physicians assistants gave us this
document that says differences between
Pas and NPS NPS follow a patient
centered model in which they focus on
disease prevention and health education
as well as handling assessment diagnosis
and treatment Pas follow a disease
centered model like physicians in which
they focus on the biologic and
pathologic components of Health etc etc
so they aren't the same so yes the and
in in their uh comparison of the
training there is more training for
physicians assistant which makes sense
based on what they tell you that they
that their the task is uh I'm I'm not
going to vote for this and maybe I'm the
only person in the room that thought if
I had a physician's assistant that there
was a doctor in the building for them to
talk to apparently I've been wrong about
that in my entire life um that's a
different conversation but that's as far
as I'm concerned that's not right you
can't how do we untether the person from
the the the the doctor and then still
call him a physician's assistant
accepting what representative Simon said
about maybe the history of that so I
can't vote for
this yes I representative Lane hasn't
spoken
yet I know I'm only a sub but listening
to this and I did watch the testimony on
this bill not the subcommittee but the
first public hearing
my question in listening to what repres
representative Simon and representative
goul have said is does it give them
seven years so they have to go that
seven years and then they're free from
this supervision or collaboration and I
think you know just to give you an
Outsiders perspective on what I've been
listening to um it's not really a
question it's just I I think that should
be made perhaps more clear in the bill
because at least the way I read it it
that's not clear so thank you
representative gold thank you madam
chair thank you for that question first
I just wanted to address that um
equivalent and equal are two different
statements so I wanted to be very very
clear I was not ever insinuating that
they were equal they're equivalent in
that it gets d DET but nurses follow a a
four-year training program that has a
lot of clinical hours involved and a lot
of patient uh direct patient work
whereas physic and then they they get
their NP work most of them nowadays
online and it does not have as many of
the clinical hours involved the Su you
know the patient one to one I call it a
practicum because I'm a social worker
but I know there's a medical term for it
in the medical field whereas a PA can
have a very different first four years
of education but then their extra um
their elevated degree is where they get
the bulk of all their hours of work with
the the patients so much like a doctor
where they're doing their rounds and
what have you under a doctor's
supervision so that's where the
equivalent comes out and that's the
seven years it's 7 years of training so
nurses have seven years of training
that's different than a p
Pas have seven years of training that
are different than a nurse practitioner
at the end of the seven years of
training they are equivalent in terms of
their skills and their ability to go out
and work with patients so I I hope that
clarifies what the testimony we heard
was um Massachusetts also I would add is
has a bill that they're looking to do
and in the
talks I had with my daughter and with
the PA assistance and then this morning
what I heard had come from the medical
board and what the pa um professional
association was advocating is that we
look at what Massachusetts bill is and
that that's a very good model it will
still make our Pas out of um not have
equal ground with our nurse
practitioners if we follow a different
model we'll still have a
schizophrenic system in New hampsh where
we're treating two equivalent positions
differently but if this committee's
happier with that I'd be willing to take
the lead on looking at the Massachusetts
piece and looking at the possibility of
an amendment for next
week excellent because representative
groa and representative leus have
already signed up to look at House Bill
1271 versus House Bill 1095
and I personally wouldn't want them to
to add any additional work on their
their effort representative Gould
and I'll help I'll help representative G
you are busy I know but this is near and
dear to my heart as you know and I'm
sure representative leus
won although representative leus has
been patiently holding his hand up so I
I'm sorry I interrupted I jumped right
in excuse me well I haven't been right
yet so yes representative leus I'm all
right um try to clear the chat thank you
I mean I understand the concerns
um we but we heard testimony there is
the problem with collaboration
agreements the other thing we heard is
that although the law says that the phys
who signs a collaboration agreement has
no legal liability the insurance
companies don't believe that and as part
of signing a collaboration agreement
that Physicians are requiring the PAs to
have their insurance carry them as a
right wrer um because I I guess I don't
know the issue is they can still be sued
regardless of what we say
um and deeper Pockets yeah um probably
the case and um and I don't see um
requiring a collaboration agreement even
for limited time as actually an
improvement on this bill I disagree with
that um it's clear that a lot of Pas
have been practicing under a
collaboration agreement that is really
not doing much of anything and we
haven't seen any serious problems with
it and I mean the reason for including
that I would think a valid reason is
because um you know it is a threat to
public health and safety and there
hasn't been any evidence I've seen or we
heard that that's the case so I mean at
this point I'd like to proceed with the
uh otpa uh motion representative Simon
of the manery thank you madam chair I
just uh wanted to have the opportunity
to address representative goal's concern
um out of Littleton because I'm familiar
with it um that's a situation where the
physician's assistant had been
practicing for several several decades
um and really without any in reality
supervision although the doctor that she
was in collaboration with you know still
had signatory
responsibilities um that doctor is
retiring and once again this nurse this
um physician's assistant has been
practicing for like 30 years
um and the idea that a nurse
practitioner could have been practicing
on their own for the last 30 years and
she was going to have to go out and find
a new doctor to have a collaboration
agreement uh seemed unreasonable and I
would agree with her it seems very
unreasonable um and so I think it was a
legitimate reason to bring legislation
before the body I mean I think that's a
that's a discrepancy that's worth our
attention at the very least um and our
discussion at the very least and so I
think it was reasonable um and my point
just being just because that was its
start uh the way that it has developed
and the way the conversation has
developed since that time um has led to
once again the Physicians um assistant
um Advocates coming out and and being in
support of the bill liking the bill the
medical uh board saying that they're
neutral on the bill the um Medical
Association not being able to provide
any data that would indicate that either
nurse practitioners have caused any real
serious harm uh practicing on their own
or that the states that have are already
adopted and there are some outside of
the state of Maine um Utah I believe was
one of them I can't remember all of them
off the top of my head um Wyoming
they've been they've been practicing for
a number of years without any incident
uh increased negative outcomes for
patients uh I just think that when you
take all of that stuff into
consideration
um I just I I don't want to become
biased by the fact that
historically we have handled this
particular profession and a particular
way um and that that somehow
necessitates the idea that you know
that's necessary or or helpful even um I
don't think that I think what's being
proven over time as this has gone on and
these agreements have become somebody
signing something in Pennsylvania for
somebody who's practicing in New
Hampshire um things of that nature which
we had testimony is a reality um that we
have left we have left whatever it was
at the beginning we've left that as the
way of practicing medicine we're really
practicing almost independ ly at this
point anyway um without any harm to the
public that we know of that can be
measured in any way that could be
testified to in any way and so I just
think that we should be treating them
the same as as representative gold said
as nurse practitioners who have an
equivalent um
degree represent beart thank you madam
chair I think the bigger issue is how
can we lower the cost of health care for
the most amount of people in the state
and I I think having more people
practicing at a higher level would be
Ben beneficial with social media the way
it is if you know a doctor is hurting
people you're going to find out about it
pretty fast and buyer beare beware at a
certain point the the um second element
which I totally slipped my mind at the
time is um I'll end that that all
right thank you rip you get to
be yes represent I remember it came to
me um New Hampshire in multiple listings
has been listed as the free estate
economic reasons social reasons so I
think looking to Massachusetts for any
guidance in any regard would be a a bad
choice I'm just going to put that up
there thank you thank you represent Mani
thank you madam chair if I can um focus
a little bit on number of Pas in New
Hampshire versus number of Pas in the US
plus
140,000 uh plus Pas in the US percentage
of Pas by specialty in New Hampshire
sure is 37% are Surgical subsp Specialty
15% all other Specialties 15% Internal
Medicine General Pediatrics or General
Internal Medicine is
1.2% or emergency medicine if you think
about all the emergency medicine Urgent
Care Family Medicine Internal Medicine
uh and all other specialty in surgical
they're practicing together as a team in
a uh healthc care setting so this uh
collaboration thing is automatic in
terms of the uh organization providing
per percentage of Pas by settings in New
Hampshire
43.9% hospital setting
42.7% physicians's office or clinic 11%
Urgent Care 2.4% other settings private
practice so this is a small amount if if
you're going to
untether you're catering to
1.2% in uh specialty areas and
2.4% that would jeopardize or upset the
apple card um in other settings that is
working well in terms of urgent care or
Physician's office or hospital setting
that is providing quality care so the
last um
34% of Pas are employed by physician
groups are Solo practices so they're
already working together with Physicians
and in New Hampshire 42.4% of Pas serve
in the rural areas a typical PA
completes 56 patient visits per week
with the supervision this is as a team
so this already is working so if you not
upset the apple cart and say okay
everybody can go do independent we're
taking that safety net away so this is
just the statistics that I have I just
wanted to share it thank you represent
leus thank you I would uh maybe have a
different interpretation of that data um
I don't see any apple cart will be up
Turn on I mean if they're already
working with a Physician Group which
most of them are or a physician or a
hospital hospital um then not requiring
a written collaboration agreement is not
going to change the conditions the
situation of their employment I mean the
people that work together the medical
professionals that work together in such
a group do consult as needed that's you
know that's part of the way it works the
other thing is in the RSA existing in
the RSA that's not affected by this bill
or the amendment says phys Physicians
assistance May provide any legal medical
service for which they have been
prepared by their education training and
experience and are competent to perform
medical and and then there's a list of
ones that include are but not limited to
which I'm not going to read so I mean
they have to have had education training
experience to legally be able to do
anything um you know whether or not they
have a collaboration agreement or not um
if they're working as I said if they're
working in a doctor's office or Hospital
they're going to be under the super
they're working for somebody they're
going to be under their super
supervision and apparently there are
some number who are working um have been
working independently in effect with a
collaboration agreement with someone
that they uh rarely interact with um so
I really do not see anything which is
going to
change you know cause problems for for
Pas who are currently
working um and that's going to cause
additional risk to uh people in New
Hampshire but what I think it will do if
we eliminate that is that there are
apparently
um places that would like to hire uh
Physicians assistance but don't do that
because of the requirement of having a
collaboration
agreement um and that's you know we had
testimony on that and I was actually
very surprised when I was looking at the
Physicians um in our area or the people
to have for Primary Care in our area
under Southern New Hampshire family
practices there were no Pas and I didn't
understand why and it appears this is
the reason and you know having a
situation where they need to have a
collaboration agreement for some number
of hours I mean May offhand make sense
but my concern is it's not going to
solve that problem if they're had not
getting hired and not able to be used in
at least some areas because they can't
they have a problem getting a doctor to
assign a collaboration agreement for
whatever reason then that that isn't
going to be solved by by such an
amendment and that's why um I intend to
support the
otpa okay anyone
else
okay
the the motion is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 1222 and the the
clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakus yes representative
Bailey yes representative santon Sasso
yes representative Dolan yes
representative Gard yes clerk vote Yes
representative voyd yes representative
Brown no Representative groa no
representative Schmidt
yes representative goalie no
representative Shu no Representative
seelig no representative Davis no
representative Lane no represent gold
yes representative Smith yes
all
see I think not now I will uh we will
not put this on
consent uh I'm going to write The
Minority Report okay represent grto will
write a Minority
Report and um
representative leus will write the
majority
report and okay we are done for the day
for tomorrow we're in session
representative Simon is scheduling
subcommittees because he has a couple of
bills that need it Friday on Friday
represent groda and leus are working
out next next week yes so we we will
meet again as a full committee on
Wednesday for the to exact all of our
bills we
hope um we'll have one session at two
and another one at one in the afternoon
yeah if you can make it I get it I have
enough people okay
car yeah just a second represent s Madam
chair I just wanted to say it was a
pleasure to sub for your committee the
difference between here and my criminal
justice Committee in terms of the uh
level of equinity was level
ah yes
I
thank